three two hello everybody it is a
beautiful Monday here in Los
Angeles uh a little a little chilly but
not too bad last night we let the rler
talk even Livy D was getting rised up by
baby gr he said that a gap was so high
in
even and I show speed hitting the gritty
a grim is shaking
fornite a grim is shaking
fornite come on one more Grim is shaking
fornite one
more a grim is shaking
[Music]
fornite beautiful woo wow Zack Lewis
ladies and
gentlemen Zach is back and thank god um
hello everybody first of all beautifully
played you I the key was a little I
didn't know where where to come in the
bummer version I didn't know where it
was the bummer version yeah it was a
little darker is what do you call that
the minor key it was a minor key
rendition wow you felt that though Zach
welcome back I miss you you so much I
missed you more I doubt it I missed I
missed being here um but yeah to be back
yeah nice to have you back anyway um
thank you everybody we've got a fun show
steo is going to be joining us around 2
2:30 he's gonna be popping in and doing
the co-hosting that'll be very fun we
love steo in fact have we has Steve only
been on the podcast once
before um or no he's done it once at
least twice once in person once during
Co yes that's what it was yeah those Co
ones
are but you've done collabs with him on
your other
channel
true yeah dude so also Zach thank you
Zach he's gonna be verbalizing the sound
bites until we're tired of it I guess
yeah I feel like this is GNA be really
quick so Zach will not be using the
soundboard what about what about
audience clapping and ambient music well
I I I think for what we have upcoming I
I do have some music prepared not
acoustic guitar but some a good bed so I
think I might transition to doing the
soundboard then okay and so if there's
like audience a uh cheering required are
you going to clap uh yeah I guess yeah
yeah
okay and what if there's ambient music
required you're going to do a guitar
okay interesting wow he's a oneman show
he does it all baby he does it all he's
like this dude in San Francisco that
like tilts his head and hits the drum
and blows through a fiddle yep one man
ban anyway uh so yeah that's coming up
and then we also have uh Olivia has been
teasing us that she has
a a god ant godmother a
godmother I find it fascinating that you
have a you have a godmother and further
that you have some kind of relationship
with her that seems unusual B I don't
really think the title was given when I
was a baby it's just like they're my
parents best friends so that's how I
describe them I what's your
argument you want to fight about it what
do you mean what do you mean what's my
argument I think he's it was a sound he
was referencing Dennis Prager incest I'm
getting used to it yeah yeah it may take
a minute more like this what's your
argument what's your argument what's
your argument oh that was good who said
that that was crazy the hell what's your
argument what's your argument what's
your argument
everything he says is like he's on the
verge of
death he's going to K over and die
Sandra and Bryant are your your Fairy
God Parents
yeah they're here to administer
acupuncture to me to uh do you unlock
Chi or is that something else do you
unlock Chi Shandra unlock I move Chi's a
chi mover I'm a chi mover and guys don't
don't worry I she knows that I'm a hater
skeptic and we are approaching this with
that in mind and that we're having a
good time a fun time and so don't be
silly thank you so with all that being
said we're gonna I'm GNA probably wait
till steo gets here to do the
acupuncture because I have a feeling
he'll put the needles in his eyeballs or
something C oh God I hope not yeah dude
he'll look around and move the needle
like whoa that'd be awesome
um so I've got all kinds of fun stuff
though to talk about top of the show
here lonus Tech tips who we Dan gave a
quite an endorsement to last week he
busted out the
um the lonus tech tick screwdriver
that's been discontinued right oh yeah
topics has it been discontinued I hope
not I think they said it's been discon
really bommer
I wait I think they just do uh limited
drops of it oh okay because I was going
to say you seem to be the only one it
seemed like a nice one though it is nice
it's not yeah it's still available you
give an authentic uh endorsement here
put your balls in my mouth yeah put your
balls in my mouth Zach
said not right now Zach not right now
buddy 70 bucks that seems pricey for a
screwdriver though doesn't it yeah it
definitely is very 70 bucks listen if
Dan if Dan endorses it then it it must
be worth the money I mean it does have
cool features but like if I go look for
like a highend what's a high-end
screwdriver that's such a funny you're
looking at it screwdriver Home
Depot let me see
ifot Home Depot Home Debo uh I mean this
is 20 bucks but that's like you know
that's dime a dozen mhm let's look
for the highend where's that high-end
man where's the good like I
guess this is looks I mean that's a
similar product 21 bucks now again I'm
not going to be a hater cuz I know what
the differen is between like Mass
producing this stuff and creating more
of an artisan type of product like these
guys probably make like a 100 thousand
of these 100 you know where lonus maybe
makes like a thousand that was Klein
Tools by the way that was your your
version but that being said it is quite
pricey uh go ahead lonus we love
you all are they hot
ones oh oh man okay this is really
turning into the merch show but Dan it's
the WAN show they did this all for me
Wayne producer of the H3 podcast mhm
ironically yeah I was like what every
every podcast has a Dan they're all
named Dan oh recently called the LT
screwdriver hey do do they have my
audio they should they they can is that
is you think so love based on what based
so love says he thinks they sold 40,000
of them well it's a very like random
guess but they have 8,000
reviews oh for real yeah 8,000 reviews
and I'm thinking probably one in five
customers usually it's one in 10 I feel
like yeah exactly I'm being generous so
holy it yeah I they it's a very
popular screwdriver these guys Crush
dude lus is that's crazy make 70 70
bucks times 40,000 how much cheddar
cheese is that that's 2.8 million in
screwdrivers cheese I I just wanted to
counteract that they do sell a lot they
probably almost Mass produc it right wow
so then you're then you're really saying
we got to we got to do something about
that price yeah I think it's a little
bit steep I mean you've already got the
guac brother let's you know 2.8 Milli I
bought one for for my dad does he love
it well no he hasn't gotten yet I'm
going to bring it to Christmas so I hope
he doesn't
I
think although he knows now cuz he
watches right he does watch the show hi
Hawk love you y still we love you we
never forget can I go back to doing my
job now already no no no no like three
minutes no you're doing a good job hit
me with that that uh Hawk scream again
though there yeah you got to put your
heart in it man yeah I'm going to need
more sound bites I feel like you're not
doing as many
okay all right go ahead lonus if that is
your real name is that a oh oh on your
laptop sorry is that a thing that can be
had uh yeah play I'm not hearing
anything from you got it now ready you
got it now okay here we go here we go
here we go here we go do you want to be
able to hear it all right good let me
see if I can get through it to you
you're going to hear some slapback
though bro your
sucks bro you don't you aren't you the
one with the Tech
podcast
[Music]
are you playing it bro you
guys okay oh really yeah it was the last
time oh wow I definitely hear what
you're calling slapback they if they had
a button they'd be hidden it that is
it's muted in the player pretty rough oh
see we've had this problem before no wor
there's a problem right there there you
go all right cool ready mhm oh by the
way shout all
right
Wonder
no technical things happen but I hope
you guys appreciate just how great our
show is sometimes you
know not judging them not hitting they
do have the biggest Tech podcast maybe
of ever in the whole world's history so
you would expect them to you know be
better than us but they're not really
are they they have the wrong
Dan well they say that in a second it's
not your fault I'm I'm being silly but
uh also respect what we do please thank
you our Dan you know their Dan would be
able to get audio to the h no you're not
sending me audio you're doing a great
job play the video oh by the way now it
you're not well what what a great
endorsement from
Dan do they ever um do they ever get to
it uh eventually well they when they
finally get it working it's the part
where I'm like don't they have a giant
controversy going on right now isn't
everybody mad at them let me watch like
oh boy sounds funny I can pretty quiet
there
fellas to lus some people are mad at
them yeah people are mad at them
pretten they finally get it work how
many time okay um
is okay hold on hold on sorry I have an
idea I have an idea you're going to hate
it are you ready for
this I oh my I've got it now no the
biggest Tech podcast in the world folks
he's going to pull it up on his phone
and play it into the mic right you can
play it
now jeez I was just going to hold my
phone up to the mic you just got to
threaten him with that we should make a
Tech podcast I know about technology I
have a smart phone I have iPhone yeah
that's true beep beep beep that's true
you do I watched you fix a computer I've
changed RAM have you wow oh
yeah big time I've changed graphic cards
too I have you know really yes I have I
also built a computer once it didn't
turn
on and I had to return all the parts oh
I'm sorry but I did build a computer it
was probably wasn't your fault I'm
afraid I can't do that probably wasn't
your fault it's not your fault I told
you that right I I uh I always wanted to
build my own computer and when we moved
to LA because computers are so freaking
expensive in Israel like all the
imported gadgets and stuff mhm so the
first thing I wanted to do is build my
own PC and um
I went to Amazon I ordered all the
parts they all came this was a big
moment for
me I got in there did all the plugging
and screwing and pasting and all the
clamping yep wiring Cable
Management
mhm you close it
up and then the moment of Crisis comes
there's one switch Circle to to
line you flip the
line the electricity is in now what do
you do there's one thing left to push
the power button and to pray yep and I
pushed the power button that day my
friends and I prayed that
button and God did not answer my prayers
and I've been an Atheist ever since that
computer never turned really that was
the day you lost your faith and I I'll
tell you what man I also gave some
respect for Amazon that day because I
returned every single one of those
open and used products no
questions asked right no questions asked
unbelievable what a company and I got to
say man Jeff Bezos give it up for Jeff
Bezos you know Jeff Bezos might be
down the open throat of hell
yes the working
class but God damn it he hooked me up
that day two day free shipping though
one day dude they even two day that's
too long these days right it's like same
day bro right I ordered like a dog chew
and they're like it'll be there by five
it's already there yeah it's on your
porch right now we already anticipated
what you were going to order and charge
your account it is so anyway um kind of
dramatic I don't know should I keep
watching this h no we got the G we love
you lius it's thanks lius thanks for the
thanks for the shout
out oh Zach is that Kurt uh Cobain back
there with you hell yeah
dude could have got a nicer photo sound
bites unplugged sound bites unplugged
that's
awesome yeah um Enrique and glacius was
a a big topic for us last week the man
he can't sing he's beautiful though
that's what I
hear thrusting could use work maybe I
don't know it's hard to tell from
humping the floor if it's good motion or
not that being said I wondered to myself
if this was autotuned would it sound
good cuz I thought yeah the voice he's
singing in seems so weird and
unnatural that maybe he's doing it on
purpose for the autotune well we got an
answer to that question uh from an
alternative no this this is goddamn this
is him performing on today yeah it was
like one of those morning shows he's on
a
crane uh play David's not
driving and uh here he is with the
autotune to give you an idea of how good
it may
[Music]
sound it doesn't sound better in fact I
would even say that uh what's the
general who got autotuned uh by the
those Christian guys to your knees yeah
what was this right Michael Flynn yeah I
think Michael Flynn sounded better in
the autotune
Journey dude yeah so shout out to
Eng glaas man really you can have a
whole ass career if you're a neppo
baby that's incredible man
incredible
look he's he's on a this man is on a
crane and people are cheering for him
and he sounds like that it's scissor
lift Ean scissor lift excuse
me that's why I'm The Tech Guy scissor
LIF I apologize you're right do you want
to try his uh shitty uh autotune thing
or the the original clip the all I
need do you want to try
that what would you like to try that
sure yeah I'd like to try it I don't
know what that means exactly you know
him him uh singing really shitty yeah
you you want to try that what do you
mean try that do you want to sing it do
I want to sing it you're the soundbite
guy I think what Zach's saying is he
knows that song on guitar and he can oh
so let me P okay well then damn you you
got to use your words a little I don't
know I want to try that I was pretending
like I knew what he was talking about I
don't I don't for the record I don't
know that song oh so then what the hell
did you mean the problem up with some
chords I don't know you want to so is
that what you meant when you said try it
do you want to sing it Zach no I I'll
sing it I'll sing it I'll pulling up the
lyrics All I need you're all I
need wait this I'm ryth Rhythm Divine is
the name of the song Rhythm oh what the
is this song then Rhythm Divine you
can just look up a Here chord chart
Rhythm Divine
so I haven't heard this whole song in qu
I'm just going to go to the chorus you
know here GD minor FC that's
it all I
need is is the Rhythm Divine there you
go lost in the music your heart will be
mine all I
need is the look in your
eyes Viva
say you'll be mine all I
need is the Rhythm
Divine lost in the music your heart will
be mine all I
need is the look in your
[Music]
eyes say you'll be mine hey wow wow that
was some all I
need but he does the falsetta right all
I need
is the Rhythm
Divine that one's not better
yeah music your heart will be mine okay
thanks Zach we did it I tried it
beautiful
bra I tried it proud of you did you uh
get a text yet
Ethan huh did you get a text yet oh
thanks for asking I'm waiting for
stea yeah did so here let me maybe I'll
give him
uh should I give him your number Dan to
text you when he's here yeah it's
probably a better
idea
yep
nope yep I kind of missed the sound
bites I don't know if it this is better
should we do a poll let's see if the
people want the sound b or they want you
know what the people are going to say
they're going to want want everybody
seems to
be this is fun we're switching it up we
do sound bites every day you know yeah
but I wasn't here Friday uh true should
we go back to the sound bites thanks for
telling me so I I gave him your number
uh danan copy that
ethaniel ethaniel ethaniel all right we
got a
pull should we go back to the sound ban
I'm here's the thing I'm torn in that I
missed it so much on Friday right but
now that I'm
here
um it is fun but is it that fun it feels
fresh it feels new it I love it it's
good time injecting some life into this
dead podcast bro it's true we need to
spice it up where we can looks like uh
the audience disagrees though they want
the sound B are you serious I mean the
yes is winning now they said what they
said no to this bit they said this bit
is ruining the show well they're saying
it's a bad poll so maybe it's just a bad
poll should we go back to the sound
bites now that's pretty clear wow I mean
we gotta listen to the people I think we
have to do more at least Zach were you
saying obscene things like Oh no just
like uh what's some Choice ones that are
really up to say death to all
Jews go
on show us do the H uh show us uh child
pornography U there it is what else uh
just so I can get this over want to come
back to my car and suck my car yeah you
want come back to my car close the trunk
what about this one you want to your
teeth you want some
teeth I love him Ela said you're doing
great Zack oh than yeah El's so wait
what are the other ones Ian can you
recall any ones you want him to say the
the shut up shut shut up yeah yeah
oh say it again sorry I went over you
shut up good that's good really
good um what about Vin Diesel ah God oh
my God you're so
beautiful all right can I do my job now
hold on
there's more Vin Diesel ones talk to me
baby okay why do this turn into
Beautiful
World um I support genocide oh good how
about uh I thought the was
white I thought the was white oh
that's good really good good delivery
there really good Pitch Perfect
she's back by the way I saw she she she
gave us a new I thought the was
white there was some other choice over
the weekend there was some other good
ones in there too is there any that you
want uh that you have in mind or anybody
there's a lot in chat I'm seeing a lot
I'm looking at the chat makeup bag oh
there's ones in chat okay let's see um
oh the Boogie monologue and Seaman is
another type of milk Seaman is another
type of milk really good that good that
was really good
OJ you want some fresh new
girls that's good um see this is better
we'll just do them all the funny ones
and then we can move on okay um
chestnuts chestnuts you want me to
perform that I guess yeah it's pretty
[Music]
good
whoa bro you didn't even say say you
didn't even say ask
twice you got to sing it like a Nook
though chill Ro roing on an open
fire wow Jack fro sleeping
in I don't know the
[Music]
words oh that
finish Jack Frost slurping over
open
fire
that was good that was good oh Grandma
pubes Grandma's pubes Grandma's pubes
Jordan Jordan Peterson's dream oh uh I
dreamed I saw my maternal
grandmother wait how did it go at the
bank of a river the bank of a
river her genital region was exposed
dimly uh wait uh wait I why have I not
memorize that word for word there's just
so much um for me that's a peace and
love kind of situation yeah hold on can
we transcribe it we should do the Boogie
one you love I'm not keep going
though as best as you can recall I
dreamed I saw my maternal grandmother by
what was it by the by the bank of a by
the bank of a river her genital region
was exposed dimly dimly yeah uh how does
he get into the paintbrush she she her
her pubes were matted like a paintbrush
something like that her
pubic oh we got it all transcribed
go check um Discord okay go
ahead I dreamed I saw my maternal
grandmother sitting by the bank of a
swimming pool there was also a river in
real life she had been a victim of all
time I don't remember this part yeah
what the f I think we cut that part out
cuz it was sad uhip it then yeah her
genital region was exposed dimly that
the appearance of a thick mat of hair
she was stroking herself absent-mindedly
she walked over to me with a handful of
pubic hair compacted into something
resembling a large artist paintbrush she
pushed this she pushed this at my face I
raised my arm several times to deflect
her hand
finally unwilling to hurt or interfere
with her any further I let her have her
way nice go on that's the only part that
I play that's usually what yeah that's
the what are you talking about she
stroked my face with the brush gently
and said like a child isn't it soft I
looked at her ruined face and said yes
Grandma it's soft where is that
part hold the phone okay I'll
tell you the problem here you're telling
me that was there the whole time no it
wasn't cuz the clip I pulled it from had
Careless Whisper playing over it oh what
the what does that mean there was music
there was copyrighted music at the end
so iut from audio cut yes well hold on
can we can we run it through AI we could
yes now we can okay dude he liter we
literally cut this out she stroked my
face with the brush gently and said like
a child isn't it soft I looked at her
ruined face and yes said yes Grandma
it's
soft my
God bro you can I would die before I
told this story yikes if I had some P if
I had some dream where my grandma was
putting her pubes all up in my face I
would have took that to the
Grave oh my God there's a bunch of AI
art of him with his grandma in heaven oh
no oh wait did he die no he didn't die
but his dream I'm why is he in heaven
he's he's dreaming of his grandma in
heaven I can't wait to be reunited with
Nana and her long flowing
pubes Gizzy
sounds why you torturing me man go
ahead isn't it like
[Music]
this okay all right um people are saying
also sorry we're I think we're almost
done a ruined face what does that even
mean I'm assuming it's a reference to
the Alzheimer's which makes it kind of
sad and I don't like that true really
sad I don't like to uh acknowledge the
realness if there's any real
psychological aspect or consequence to
it I don't want that yeah just want it
to be funny I sent that album if you're
curious so it's pretty
sweet um I think we got most of it Kim
Kardashian
ones get your ass up and work
what about Bo
blacks oh true do the 500 Subs
man nobody gives a about
you how about allegations talk about the
allegations well that was really good
dude you're awes you've been studying
Dam you've been studying
bro oh Mobility Mary I need to get out
of this stream mhm mhm go
away let see what else is there uh uh
her you got to give me her oh my God
which one there's like two okay either
Vari oh my
God and there's oh my
God okay wait I have a good request Zach
the bo Black song
yeah good call yeah definitely pass
up on that
one
um
[Music]
how always get
bullied what about um weights and
fish oh yeah weights and fish is good
one we got weights and fish damn okay
makeup bag uh makeup bag it might have
been a little too fill that bag up fill
that bag up right now there it is nice
yeah FY FY
ones uh it tastes like beef
jerky um wait how old are
you
uh I think that's it I think we get it a
lot Kanye so oh yeah the Kanye ones are
good ninja talking about Kanye is that
Kanye no no no no like what he remember
what Kanye said about the Jews and stuff
oh yeah yeah oh um we got to stop
dissing the Nazis all the time we got to
stop dissing the Nazis all the time and
then there was a the ones um uh I can
even say anti-semitic I can say
anti-semitic things in Adidas can't drop
me MH now what now
what all right anything
else uh let's see uh See
5% yeah no okay all right I think we're
good all right we're fine so yeah okay
thank you Zach well done amazing what a
guy what a guy what a talent you
probably suspect it but that was all a
rusee
I bet just to get you on audio saying
all that I bet
yeah well very good and it
works but thank you for playing
along ah he's back he's back we love it
yeah I think Steve is here
right Stevie your boy Steve can I call
him Steve I wonder should ask family
call him Steve St Steven the man is she
call him
Steven Hello Steven full government
because like this man he turned he's
steveo there's nobody walking around
Steve O right Steve O is his last name
start with an o that' be interesting we
don't even know what's ste's last name
isn't it his last name is clover oh so
it's not not so no okay okay all I need
is the look in your
eyes be I love music the heart will
survive um
oh speaking of which real quick Rosanne
[Music]
uh there he
is yeah dude what's up it's been a while
huh oh sh you're Ling you okay um yeah
I oh so um yeah dude join me love
it been a while huh D it has been way
too long my brother
you've been good though you've been busy
you've been working all kinds of cool
creative stuff I have been uh yeah I've
been busy I've been creative life is
good nice you know I said this in uh my
weekly men's
meeting it's a bunch of men who get
together to talk about their feelings is
that right yeah I love that I mean it's
like a it's like a sobriety thing oh
that's wonderful thank you sir that's
great this past week I said
guys I would be hardpressed to imagine
how my life could be any better I have a
great life nice but I spend it just in a
ball of anxiety and stress all the time
and I wonder if when my life ends if I
won't think damn it why couldn't I have
just relaxed a little bit and just
enjoyed myself but you know where I
arrive at in
conclusion
is that it's that anxiety that stress
that discomfort which constantly drives
me to try to keep working and striving
and that's what's made my life so good
there's definitely truth to that
absolutely
anxiety is a fuel for greatness I think
have you tried um any medicine any
medication for that I do take zoft okay
that's good it it helps yeah that's I
take Alexa and I found it helped me a
lot yeah cuz I I was super an anxious
mess too um I uh dude there's so much to
talk about and catch up on thank you I
want everybody to know that I uh texted
Ethan asking if I could just crash on to
the show if I could just invite myself
anytime anytime and it means so much to
me and to see this new headquarters yeah
how long you've been here God we've been
here a while it's been way too long man
like two years maybe two years it's
pretty epic man thank you man
um there's just so there's just so much
to get into so what I'm Cur what kind of
stuff are you anxious about if you're
comfortable saying oh I'm I'm I'm I'm an
open book what's what occupies your mind
when you get you know
uh I would say
overall um fear of like losing
everything and everything's not going to
be okay oh and and like I'm just going
to I don't know it doesn't make sense
everything's going great and you're
afraid that it will stop going that
great yes I see what you're saying yeah
everything's not going to be okay and I
know that it's patently not true right
I'm going to be okay and I just can feel
it all over my body I'm just like I
think that might be some kind
of people that came up from like uh
difficult places and like found this
like uh stability and success and stuff
I think it's probably somewhat common of
a I don't know how to refer to it of an
of an anxiety yeah to have that fear
even irrationally right totally
irrationally yeah there's um you know I
saw some YouTube video about like
anxiety leads to Greatness and there's
some guy who developed this Theory it
name is like kard or something like that
and I don't mean to be a douche like try
to suggest that I'm great but um I will
go so far as to say that I think that
anxiety is um is beneficial to me so
there it is yeah and and man dude I sent
you that text last night like hey if
you're looking for something to watch
holy did I raise the bar this time
so let's we can give that a shout out
real fast Ste so you're so what is it
you're there's a a showing of it on
moments it is streaming for limited time
on moment this is my bucket list special
remember the first time when uh when I
got on the H3 podcast with you I had not
yet done done the thing I told you that
I was going to be duct taped to a
billboard yeah on a truck well I saw the
pictures of it recently yeah I and like
that was my deal I was like I was like
I'm going to have a billboard for my
comedy special on one of these billboard
trucks my buddies are going to duct tape
me to the billboard truck and then just
drive me down the highway duct tape to a
truck right right and and man like I
remember it was it was ambitious I said
I was going to do it I totally did it
and for this one this is the my special
since that one this one just came out
it's called steo bucket list okay and
for this one I was like man how am I
going to get to the theater this time I
was like dude I want to be on the roof
of a building have a huge helicopter
above me it drops a rope ladder I grab
the rope ladder with my bare hands and
get whisked off into the you know like
crashed through all different kinds of
stuff and then I want the helicopter to
find my moving tour bus and let go of
the rope and land on the roof of the
moving tour bus and uh it was the most
how did that go you did that oh 100% it
was the most expensive the most hectic
and it could not have been more like it
could not have turned out better and so
then after shooting that I get Bill Bur
my podcast and you probably know Bill
Burr is a helicopter pilot yes so I I
showed him like what I what I had cut
together and I was like Bill what do you
think about we shoot you flying a
helicopter to get insert shots to make
Bill bur and and dude he he what a bro
he said you rent the helicopter I'll
flying he flew it holy we had
already done the stunff yo that would
been crazy if like you both died
we had already done the stunts we just
filmed to get insert shots to to cut in
so that we could cut back and forth to
show Bill bur that's awesome oh so he
didn't fly the he didn't do the stunt
but he he agreed to to be in it like uh
oh man just so so The Bucket List was
like these can I show that shot you said
I have the link but I don't know if you
want me you know what go go ahead and
and show show s pretty cool dude it's
unbelievable the whole hold on you sent
me the access I'll send it to Dan if
that's okay yeah and then Dan can log in
so
dude uh hold on one sec here
Dan that's just at the very beginning
it's at the very beginning I want to see
that it would be a nice teaser yeah I
mean d the whole thing is so utterly
well congrats I'm glad that you
made something you know
U that you're really happy with I think
that's awesome it is the greatest thing
I've ever made I remember when we first
got together you were talking about you
wanted to do St stand up and I was
saying I did wow my I've changed my mind
on that so much I you want I was doing
stand up and you were podcasting yeah
and we wanted to respectively get into
it oh and I started podcasting I love it
and I didn't do and I didn't stand up I
never did yeah you can read the warning
it's it's it's like systematically gets
can I can I ask you something sure is it
difficult for you to
talk um sometimes it feels like do you
is there effort that goes into getting
the words out it feels like difficult
yeah I I just cuz your voice is
so I made a video called why my voice is
so messed up yeah and and I really tried
to investigate what's going on with it
has it always been like that yeah huh
and and the what I arrived at or what
I've learned was is that um I don't I
use like the like the muscles and not
the V vocal cords oh interesting yeah I
just like I I just don't use my voice
properly for no particular reason for no
reason that I can understand and and
that was kind of the conclusion I was
like wow really doc after everything
I've been through I just suck at talking
yeah turns out that way can you yell I
can yeah yeah can you yell for me yeah
dude is that it I guess oh my that's
awesome dude I mean I had to ask because
um I it it it well just it just yeah I
go back and forth being like
self-conscious about it or feeling like
it's just trademark and I hope you don't
feel self-conscious it's very much the
trademark it's tra I mean dude I if I
order a pizza like odd arm get
recognized on the phone that's crazy get
recognize on the phone ordering a piz
crazy okay dude all right let's take a
look at this intro let's see you know
what I don't even care if you're to see
now
enjoy okay
great y some noise
for exciting so there it is guys uh just
a little sneak
peek um yeah I'm trying to pause it I
don't want to Pirate the whole thing
okay there you go
get yeah man I you're the you're the
first and
only uh place that I've allowed that to
be played ince thank you yeah and oh the
whole intro yeah that whole opening well
that's all I think I feel like people
should see that yeah I mean dude the
whole
like everything is just at the highest
level that I've ever operated so um
today I'm actually doing a stunt oh good
I like that and I think you'll be
impressed okay I'm going to be doing
acupuncture nice I think that that I
think that that might have Merit that's
a huge uh physical uh feat for
me um and I hope that you'll be
impressed by it I would I'll absolutely
be impressed and before we move on while
we're on the bucket list I just want to
explain what how the show Works what it
is right go ahead like I had these
forbidden stunts that I would not have
been able to do for Jackass there just
too much i' never even thought to do
them because they're just so absurd and
then I thought you know what I'm going
to make this multimedia show I'm going
to go for all of it and like in the
opening sequence I give the flowers to
my girl like the the show is a love
story and the bucket list stunts are
presented in descending order of my
fiance's approval and support that's
funny in the beginning she's front and
center shooting it participating
facilitating and um gradually she
becomes less stoked what was the F the
the ultimate the ultimate conflict the
where we end up at uh was my plan to go
skydiving for the first time completely
butt naked with another man strapped to
my back furiously masturbating Jesus man
to completion where complete
yeah and I got to simultaneously time it
so that I'm falling out of the airplane
as I'm ejaculating you're wait you're
jerking off yeah yeah
evacuation someone on your back it's
tandem you got to have guy St to your
back okay okay so you're jerking offer I
thought someone else was jerking off
your off with another man strapped my
and what was her problem with that well
like like like she she just weird about
me like even showing my wiener on camera
let alone having a boner let alone
jacking off to another woman because the
plane was full of dudes so I had to I
had to have a a DVD player oh you so you
brought I brought a DVD player media
with you yeah and she just felt like
like that just women are weird like that
dude that's so it wasn't the bodily harm
you know it wasn't the that she wasn't
afraid you were going to die or anything
right there but earlier she stopped
showing up for stunts earlier in the
show like when I get the the 4in needle
in my spine you know what an epidural is
yeah they inject a drug into your spinal
Cavern that to just paralyze you
and so I got this medical professional
oh you did that that's what women do
when they're when they give birth right
crazy you feel nothing yeah I did it in
the field dude I did this this medical
professional like
stole the drugs from the hospital good
and like gave it to me in a field right
like he injects the drug into my spinal
cavity yank Yanks out the 4-in needle
and I take off running to see how far I
can go and then like my buddies have to
figure out how paralyzed I really
actually am so it's very SCI paralyzed
or do you just numb cuz well I know that
like for example Ela did a epidural on
her first baby she was just in bed
though she wasn't attempting to Sprint
anywhere you are absolutely
paralyzed and the thing is that um like
I ran the idea by my buddy Dr Drew he's
like super freaked out by it he's like
dude like I know you're going to do it
but just watch out if you've become come
paralyzed above the waist cuzz it can
back up you know and then you're going
to have your systems shut down and uh
was there a doctor nearby spoiler alert
that's what happened like was there a
doctor nearby you had medic like I had
two medical
professionals that's good so yeah I mean
that was the one where Lux stopped
showing up that's pretty that's pretty
hectic she said there's certain things
in life you can never unsee and she
could not just bring herself to witness
one of them so so um so you were you
afraid you wouldn't be able to finish in
the air or did it take more than one
jump um it didn't take more than one
jump there was so much invested in it
like did you take viager or something I
I had a I had four seis pills for CU you
want to make sure and I I backed myself
up for four days oh okay okay and and
and uh you know because I identify as a
sex addict I'm in recovery like i' like
been years since I stopped is that a new
revelation uh I didn't know that about
you a sex addict rehab in
2013 okay like right around the time I
first got on YouTube I see so yeah like
I I I stopped watching pornography years
ago and and what was your poison as it
as it were uh I mean it it was kind of
like uh multifaceted but but I I would
be in the the tug and rubs that's that's
so interesting I was speaking to another
guy who was uh expressing he had this
exact same thing with the with the
massage yeah with the with the tug and
rub and there's just this like shame
when you walk out of a tug rub like
who's going to like see me com out of
you know like and and there was there
was just a a lot like I would act out on
the road a lot I see I would I would
always do like meet and greets after the
show like with the whole audience
partially because I wanted people to go
home with the photo to post and say hey
wow steo standup was really pretty good
you know and partially because I wanted
to find somebody to act out sexually
with you know I think think it's the
fact that you're being honest about that
I think there's probably a lot of
performers that do it that do that for
that reason and they they don't they
don't say that yeah big time man like I
I was approaching 40 years old and I'm
like dude this isn't it this isn't like
the path to being happy M you know like
a and uh especially like when we're in
entertainment like I'm particularly
sensitive to it because what I do is so
like Adolescent and and childish that it
feels like not permissible for steo to
get old on some level you know and and
and maybe I'm in my head about it but I
just feel like man I gotta I gotta have
some balance in my life I cannot have my
self-esteem my selfworth like tied to my
success as steo because then it's just
like a the future scary true yeah you
know I I got to learn how to be in a
healthy relationship and oh can you
drift in a bit you oh yeah over there
got to find a life partner to help me
like you know like and uh it took a lot
of work man so how long you been with
your fiance uh almost seven years oh wow
and I I read that you went through a
bout of celibacy was that with her while
you were with her it was not it was not
that was that was after I went to the
sex addict rehab in uh 2013 so how long
were you celibate they they they
recommended a period of 30 to 90 days
because and that's no masturbating corre
Elvis does not leave the building okay
and um you uh like like it's supposed to
rewire your brain somehow you know and
then how and then you can start over
with like a a a new and healthy approach
to sexuality interesting and for me like
I was very clear that my goal was to to
be in a healthy relationship find a life
partner and like really have because
that's like what where longevity and
happiness like a solid marriage married
people are happier and um I uh had such
a shitty checkered past was I was just
such a scumbag that um I I wanted to to
Really really go crazy with the celibacy
to put distance between me and being a
scumbag and to prove to myself and to my
future partner that I could do it so I
went for like a stupid long time it
ended up being
431 days sh wow the entire year of 2014
I did not W and how was was it difficult
did it get easier um it there were times
when it was more difficult than
others um there I was certainly very
irritable for that whole year of 2014 I
would really snap on people interesting
um but I went into the the beginning of
2014 I had less than 1 million Facebook
followers by the end of 2014 I think I
had 8 million there's something there
the fan retention yeah I mean dude like
you were driven and like all of my
energy was just channeled into like go
go go and I love that and so when did
you finally bust uh in I believe it was
February of
2015 and what was the situation I at
that point I had arrived at the
conclusion that that the the usefulness
of my
caby streak with like had really you did
it it had reached the point of
diminished returns at this point I was
just being sexually anorexic it was
actually unhealthy I felt at that point
and so I just tugged one
out you went where is it in a hotel room
I was in a hotel room in Austria in
Austria I was in a hotel room in Austria
I was filming a a British TV show called
The Jump where where celebrities
competed at winter sports and and um I
uh I I the the the load landed on my
tummy oh God it was it was entirely uh
unimpressive was it like Dusty wasn't
Dusty you know I had jokes in my standup
uh about like what it might be like you
think it's going to be huge but it's
it's just like think it's going to be
like a fire hose or like a big
marshmallow falling out
like um but uh it was it was
UN unimpressed underwhelming it didn't
even feel great
interesting so the act so when you
finally did it wasn't the cathartic that
you were hoping it would be yeah and and
the worst thing I was in an actual like
formal men's Therapy Group like not not
like a the meeting I was talking about
earlier but like an actual with a
therapist like a group group therapy M
and the the therapist was a woman and I
sent the picture of my tummy with the
load on it to the whole on a text thread
and J the guys in my group were were
horrified by they were just like what
are you doing that that is
horrific you sent that to a woman they
weren't offended for themselves right
they didn't care for themselves did she
comment on it she didn't but uh we just
pretend it didn't happen yeah kind of
thing yeah it like I had kind of
unplugged I was in Austria for like
shoot maybe like six to eight weeks and
uh I kind of went a little crazy out
there oh God so once you B once you
broke the seal you went crazy what does
that mean I mean I didn't go crazy but
uh once I broke the seal um I uh you
know at that point like I was trying to
negotiate with myself like what what's a
healthy approach to masturbation like my
masturbation plan like like am I doing
when you say crazy you're talking about
masturbating yeah and and um you know
like I I got crazy like I got like crazy
um
infatuated like uh got got got in a
couple relationships that that weren't
like necessarily compatible or like
great great call I had a couple misfires
with relationship okay and so what did
you what is your masturbating schedule
now yeah now I I just don't do it if I'm
home with my girl yeah the only time
I'll ever do it is uh if my girl and are
apart you're on the road right because I
I don't want to um Channel my Sexual
Energy away from my
relationship that's good you know I
think it's it's it's healthier to to
save it up and keep it within between me
and my fiance now if I am on the road
like uh I'm not I'm not too worried
about it I don't want to do it daily no
I don't want to do it daily but I'm not
going to beat myself up if I do what's
important to me is that when I'm going
to be back with my lady that I let
myself get a little bit backed up
interesting you know I let myself get a
little bit so I've really got a good one
in the chamber for her when uh there it
is masturbating schedules and strategies
yeah it is I wonder do women have this
issue where they need to stop
masturbating or is that like a guy you
know what I mean I'm sure you know that
there's got to be some out there but I
feel like that's that's a that's a man's
world uh I wouldn't be surprised man I
think uh and you know what maybe yeah
maybe I'm maybe I'm off yeah I think
you're tripping like when it comes to
anything that feels good there's a 12ep
program for it yeah yeah yeah yeah
anything that rules yeah yeah doesn't
that suck kind of also it does you just
want to be such a heis scumbag like I
just want to eat hamburgers and pizza
for every meal right that's my thing now
is food sucks my my thing now is
Food Dude you are you afraid you're
gaining weight and stuff you look good
you look great you're very active I
appreciate that I certainly don't look
uh my best but it's it's not even a a
vanity concern I think it's just like
like a a health issue I mean it's just
so it's so simple man like diet and
exercise are the real Main Ingredients
physical health yeah it's a simple
equation just like it's so little to get
right it's so
boring we want to consume we want
pleasure I know what's the point of
living in America right if we can't
be he in this scumbag you you
look healthy thank you there was some
crazy stuff going on with your health
there was some picture that was like I
feel like I feel like he retweeted or
something I was bald there there was
like I forget what it was but there was
like an image of you that was like
really shocking and horrifying and I was
like oh no what's going on with sure
yeah you could describe a lot of images
of me in that
way but you look great now I've lost a
lot of weight yeah I've lost probably
like 70 lbs since about a year plus ago
I was at 250 it was it was it was quite
uh quite it was quite a thing is this
one you're talking about that's okay
yeah so this one isn't actually real
yeah I mean I'm guessing that that's a
lot of people think it's real in in fact
I made it my avatar after I lost most of
the weight and of course I have I have a
I'm known for my hairline so just going
to put throw that out there right that
is not my hairline okay good I I saw
that and and and it was like you had
tweeted it and or made it your your
avatar like I I was just like man what's
going on yeah no it was it was a tough
situation for sure I felt like I was
never going to lose the weight I was
stuck the worst the person that really
me up the most was the Bobby Lee
can you guys pull up the Bobby Humpty
Dumpty Bobby Lee show up photos this is
right before I started going on my big
weight loss Journey that's good I was on
Bobby Lee's podcast and he those guys
did me so damn dirty with that camera
angle they put on Me Hold on let me show
you
this oh that's that's what what I looked
like though they didn't change it but
hold on you got to see my like dainty
little feet and
um it's uh it's crazy dude um I'm in a
large right now your role in the in the
whole uh Bobby
Lee Saga with the that whole drama with
the all the other comedians yeah I love
Bobby I I did too I'm like protective of
him because I love him and I don't like
those guys being dicks to him I
but I don't know what's your relation I
know you're there are certain people who
I took a stand on for Bobby you did yeah
good took a stand for Bobby and um and
and that's how it is the thing is like
if you're going to be a dick to Bobby at
least be funny right you know if you're
a shitty comedian and being a dick to
Bobby then you really just have nothing
going on here's the photo yeah that's
that's that's how they did it that's how
they did me that's how they did you look
at those feet look how they just pointed
out was there was there still a uh a CO
partition no no there wasn't at this
time this was like a maybe how long ago
was this can I can I uh year and a
half ago year and a half yeah like the
the the whole uh Corona virus
wear a mask thing I saw one tweet that
just ended it for me okay it said farts
go through boxer shorts and jeans
yeah but right this okay okay that got
you yeah done and and then to put it
another way uh rather eloquently a a
scientist said that wearing a mask
trying to uh reduce the spread of Corona
virus is like putting up a chain link
fence trying to keep mosquitoes out
right but that's not exactly true
because the mask is to to stop the
droplets it's this because but it's not
even droplets is it well that's what
they're that's what the the concern was
the spit droplets was what was uh
spreading yeah but I don't think that's
what spreads it
dog uh it is oh is it that's not what Dr
Drew said oh yeah but that's why he's on
Rumble that's exactly what thank
you for saying that I want to say I Dr
Drew have had great uh I've had great
times with him that being said he's not
my go-to source on Co info yeah I mean
dude I like I'm gonna throw him under
the bus when when it when it happened I
was like dude Dr Drew like uh there this
new Corona virus thing like you know
like am I a Dick if I uh fill in a spot
at a big theater in in uh Austin Texas
you know like everybody's dropping out
over the virus and they're trying to F
the thing like like like are people
going to be mad at me if I book big
thousand like 1200 seat theater and he
was like dude go on with your life bro I
love that he's the he's the best he's
like the guy that just tells you what
you want to hear
I mean I love I love him and and uh on
the record I love him he's he is he's
lovable yeah he is a good guy that being
said you if you follow his Co advice you
may
die I mean like uh it's so funny it's so
funny I was just on this podcast the
other day and they sent me links to to
promote it they're like oh yeah the
numbers are pretty good on Rumble we got
demonetized on YouTube it's probably the
or who knows what he he he he goes
down some interesting holes I don't want
to get you guys in trouble for anything
no not at all yeah and if you want to
wear a mask that's great you're not
getting us in trouble good you're good
don't worry that tweet really did end it
for me though because farts go through I
mean listen that's it's an interesting
thought experiment I mean farts go
through boxer shorts they sure do
although farts are
gas okay it's not Mist it's not water
droplets it's a different form of of uh
it's a different form frankly of of
matter yeah okay it's
gas all right CU it's not we're not
worried about getting turds in our mouth
from a
fart I don't know man I think that when
you flush a toilet like there's there
might be some turds in there absolutely
I'm not opening my mouth near flushing
toilets all right I stand back when I
flush the toilet what can we get into
that's yeah yeah yeah yeah by the way
one other thing Howe Mandel also
me this is an unedited
look at this look at this shot I this is
madness ow this is absolute
Insanity thank you for your support on
that I I I I'm with you bro I stand with
you so
um okay I I want to throw this out there
I I I I might have uh like barked at a
guy who uh works for me he had said hey
dude I'm such a huge fan of the H3
podcast like he works with you yeah he
he he is doing some work for me and he
was like dude if you're ever there like
dude let me just please tag along I love
it so much and I I didn't I didn't
respond I didn't respond like you know
come on dude that's not professional I'm
I'm going to show up oh hey this is my
buddies like a big fan of yours just
awkward people do that sometimes but I I
would probably feel the same way where
it's like I don't want to impose on my
friend I felt like that just well tell
them hi I mean I appreciate the fan yeah
appreciate the love I mean I have zero
doubt that he's listening right now and
I love I I love you Eli I I do love you
Eli I love you Eli it's just like the
reason why I didn't respond the first
time that he he he sent this request
because I felt that it was just awkward
and unprofessional and then he found out
I'm coming on today and he goes hey man
he he wrote can I cash in my go on the
H3 why does he want to come here so bad
is he going to kill me I I have no idea
why does he want to get in the studio
studio so bad bro just be like all just
be like everyone else if you want to
meet me just Google my address and come
to my
house that's a joke of course uh that's
a funny funny J again I love come to my
house I love Eli but but uh he just he
just made it awkward by asking a second
time we love you we love you we love
you're very special you're very special
yeah and and and here here now like uh
he got his shine like uh there you go
love we shined you up buddy we glazed
you up all right so um we have here our
acupuncturist okay and I thought this is
a big feat for me and I thought maybe
you know as someone who's a stunt devil
sure yourself I'm a I'm a professional
self harer self harer that's a good I
like that yeah yeah um you know like
that there was a magician guy who uh had
a trick like he was like oh let me show
you like this trick I'll put uh like a
an acupuncture needle like through my
hand oh and it like wasn't a trick
it was even remotely feel it was it like
it was an acupuncture needle that just
went like straight through the whole
godamn yeah it hurt what the that's
not a trick that's an what a dick I know
what the
man do it to yourself if you want to
show me a trick is it a you're not doing
that
right have you seen that hello there I'm
not sticking a needle through your hand
no but I'm happy to stick one through
yours have you seen have you seen that
where they do it I have seen that
there's actually some techniques in
acupuncture you might do that with
resuscitation or like stroke but
technically only in China I'm trying to
remember I think he did it to
me remember now if it happened I you're
like the perfect candidate for Acure
like literally it's going to be your
best friend have you ever okay hold on
one sec where's my mic you got to lay
down on I'm going to lay down I'll take
my shoes off okay so I've got this you
can see my my angle here all
right okay the cing yeah
fire cupping fu yeah the cup the cupping
like it's kind it's mildly uncomfortable
but not it just gives you your it's like
a deep tissue massage except for it
works for de tissue massage I see videos
of that sh no no it's actually feels
easier than a deep tissue massage but it
works more effectively so what are we
working on
Ethan Excuse Me Maybe maybe that cough
so hold on you guys were talking about
oh can you address my cough via
acupuncture yes absolutely so why don't
you put your arms down and get and how
what's the science behind that uh we're
going to work on your lung Chi
deficiency and kind of move some energy
in maybe some stuck energy in your lungs
hold on before you stab me I'm not going
to I'm going to I'm going to go real
easy with the stabbing I promise okay
you'll tell me beforehand yes cuz I
can't see anything right and I'm scared
do you have any back pain no not I don't
really
have that's what not yet that's uh not
no I don't have back pain to be honest
yeah I sh I don't have back pain okay so
but Ste why were you saying that
acupuncture would be good for stea
because he has a lot of physical
injuries have you tried it before steo
he went to the bathroom he's going to be
right back
okay there we go
got okay good that shot is crazy okay
so excuse me but if you're saying you
can address the cough then first I just
want to say that the acupuncture needles
when we talk about you're saying
stabbing the acupuncture needles are
actually hair fine so they're super thin
fragile they're single use they're
they're single use okay yeah so they're
they're medical waste and I'm just going
to work on your lung right you're not
going to puncture my lung though right
urinary bladder no we're we're
100% not going to punct and then what
are you doing in my bladder I'm just
using alcohol to kind of clear the areas
that I'm going to work on and what are
you doing to my
bladder I'm a you know your urinary
bladder channel do you know what I'm a
frequent uriner Urinator can you do
something about that frequent Urinator
can you do something about that that you
could have um herbs would really be good
for that but yeah acupuncture would be
good for that too so acupuncture can
reduce my fre
urination yes and okay so now we're
going to do the first hold on hold on
hold on hold on hold on yes so my my
relationship with my dad is somewhat
strained would acupuncture help with
that it could help with maybe the stress
I'm kidding I love my we don't I was
just trying to make a joke okay you
ready we're going to do this steo are
you
[Music]
here did you stab me I did how was that
I didn't I didn't like
it I didn't like
it what do you think not so bad that one
I didn't feel so much oh wow okay so
Steve she was saying have you tried
acupuncture before I I have and did it
help you uh I can't remember that it did
anything really very great so how long
have you been practicing acupuncture for
about 12 15 years somewhere around there
and
um oh God she stabbed in my neck
dude that's
right oh what the was that you
like slingshot it into my neck
bro you stabbed me in the you're going
to put in my head I just did why the
you putting needles in my head who
authorized that what is that going
to do for
me hold on hold on hold on hold on no
ah did you get okay
so so why do so is there peer reviewed
science that says this works there's
like tens of thousands of studies on
acup peer reviewed absolutely and uh
American Medical Association can you
pull some of those up Dan pull it up Dan
pull it up I thought you were going to
say there are tens of thousands of years
of proof well there's there there it's
actually been around for over 3,000
years that's for sure I mean like but
that's why that's why Western medicine
can I move my hand I got it for it CU it
it it increases endorphins which are the
exact same thing that opioids
do zero side effects of this is there
ever a reason to put one of those in a
man's wiener yeah there is there is
actually in there holy have you
done that break it out Ethan I I've
actually done it before shut the that
his actual leer where did you where did
you put them on the sides and like the
groin
area it felt like like stuck energy and
just you know like moves energy like
right right right in between the balls
and the butthole there's that's called
the parum there is some yeah prostate
health um you know liido problems I've
never done it I'm not going to
so about that how does how does poking
someone with a needle do anything so
first of all these are these acupuncture
points are on or near nerve plexuses
major nerve plexuses in your body so
this increases a histamine reaction it
also increas is endorphin release so
endorphin is like the exact same thing
that pain does or when you have sex
that's what's released when you eat
sugar when you go for a run lots of
stuff does Rel endorphins and dopamine
well they're the basically the same
thing so you basically it's like
serotonin dopamine that's what you
release when you have oxytocin
breastfeeding when women best breastfeed
that's what the baby's like bonding over
that's what's released any sort someone
it my nose
[Laughter]
AB my right nostril my right nostril
then I applaud you the production value
of this this bit is is just really well
thank you you know we we we and that Dan
of course Dan is the uh the good Dan is
uh yeah all Dans are good we don't we
don't compare we don't compare some Dan
are better than others did you conceive
this idea to get acupuncture before or
after um
it was known that I would be here this
was planned before actually there you go
it was a happy accident cuz I like you
being here for this A happy accident
yeah are you putting in me I was
just kind of adjusting them a little bit
kind of getting some Chi trying to tap
into like little bit why why are they
laughing cuz the one in your head is
there's one just sticking out from the
top of your head is it bouncing look
crazy making you smarter I'm
going to I can I can do a little of this
don't do that don't do that
tuning it I felt that scraping my
skull oh this is this is my worst
nightmare right here is it a or I not do
well with needles you just take a couple
of deep breaths yeah and then we will do
cupping fire then we're going to do the
cup yeah yeah we you ever cup you cup
genitals or not no just okay sorry I
didn't mean to be weird I just just I
just piggy back a little weird I was
just no and I'm not asking you to be
clear asking me no no no no no I was
just I was just piggybacking on the the
needling de
genitals yeah yeah steo asked that not
me
go just to be totally clear about
everything no we we don't do cupping in
that area typically Family Farms but we
can do the legs the back I've done the
stomach for you know pregnancy for
digestion Dan what's the peer- reviewed
research on needles in the
head who Dan oh Dan yeah it it works
great um the the the cupping is going to
be like very visual because they light a
cotton ball and they throw it in the cup
and then the cotton ball burning it
burns up all the oxygen which creates a
vacuum and then you get the suction so
it will look very cool and there's a
strong possibility that it will leave an
even cooler hickey yeah and those
hickeys are actually called perpa which
actually serves a purpose of getting
more blood flow in the area for the next
few days so you actually get more relief
2 or 3 days later after instead of just
like a massage when you you know you
feel like you feel good for maybe 12
hours my person take is that if you want
to get a massage get a massage I think
that that feels good and has Mer but
like the the cupping it it to me are you
all the needles in it's uncomfortable
we're needled out it depends on how many
needles do I have in some are more
intense than do you have like different
sizes of cotton balls you want to how
many needles are there yeah you can
definitely control the level for
sometimes it feels like there's too much
suction 11 needles what do I look like
Hellraiser and sometimes they actually
if they don't do fire cupping they do
like the plastic pump cups those
actually feel worse can I ask you a
question please plastic that edges
really hard can how is it so this was
invented in China right like thousands
of years ago yeah 3,000 years ago 2500
years ago yeah a lot more like 3,000
years and it's also a complete medicine
it's it's like herbs acupuncture it's
all the mindfulness chiong Tai Chi it's
all a part of the medicine okay can we
can we make him look like Hellraiser so
he's even more mindful we're g to make
him he he's like kind of a no I don't
want I don't know I don't want more for
you I might do it I might do the
Hellraiser but he's you can do more you
can do more turn him totally off you can
do more my head it's okay you have
unlimited don't worry I'm never doing
this again and you don't have to worry
I'll do the hell razor though
I mean how many needles are we talking
about lady dude hell risor that's no
it's like 100 in your face no I don't
want that yeah it's like the whole head
face and they're actually Nails not
needles but I'm going to do just like a
calming point for you cuz you seem a
little nervous this is your heart
channel right here it's not going to
help I have Tourette Syndrome I can't
help it I'm not kidding that's not a
joke he does yeah just saying it's not a
joke ow
kidding
didn't feel great but now what does it
feel like it's just like a little Pinch
at first and then it goes away right
it's a little the idea is that you would
sit here for like 20 or 30 minutes in a
really nice quiet area and relax and I
would leave you here you wouldn't have
this you just leave me here like this
yeah I would leave you in a nice room
and then you I would like 30 minutes
what do you do when they're in there
resarch or treat another client or you
just chill or I just chill or I work on
um a new nutrition plan, wow so is this
your is this your full-time thing yes
I'm also an applied clinical
nutritionist so I do a combination I
work a lot with um hormones okay and I
work a lot with uh females trying to get
them pregnant and so the needles help
fertility amazing how it's like I mean
it just really if you want to talk about
balance I love what you're were talking
about earlier about balance this is
what's going to put you back into
balance I mean I think we came here one
to thrive not just like survive right so
why wouldn't you want to do anything
that has no side effects like it's it's
not addictive it's addictive in the way
that it might make you feel really good
why wouldn't you want to just do
anything that brought you into balance
extended your life and didn't get you
addicted to something that's going to be
really or have bad side effects like
most western pharmacology
does um why is it when you insert them
it feels like you're slingshotting it
into me is there some kind of device
you're using yeah there's like a little
it's a little guide needle like it's
like you hand you're you're
using a chisel to insert them I mean
exactly it's like this little it's this
little guide needle it's like a little
plastic tube okay and so that keeps it
nice and um does people any anyone ever
bleed from this I mean every once in a
while there's like a DOT of blood but
not like bleed bleed we definitely you
know acupuncture is like four years
full-time master's program so we know
the anatomy and the body really really
well we do 2,000 hours of clinical hours
in Western medicine situations so I did
my UCLA oh wow so we know where the
arteries are and we're kind of trying
not to stab you in a major artery they
teach acupuncture at
UCLA yeah there's an East West
integrative system there ow ow well
don't move I can't help
it hand can you cure Tourette's with
noodles you know the nervous part of it
probably can definitely calm your
nervous system down you can C my thre
this is going to calm your nervous
system down for sure okay but you have
to come in for like once a week like
four to six times and really experience
it in like my office is there a Guinness
Book of World Records most acupunctured
needles in someone oh dude there's got
to be I'm sure there probably is
yeah stea what do you think I man know
I'm curious I've been snubbed by
Guinness year after year for far too
long what do you have you actually are
you trying to get records with them okay
what's the record God that's got to be a
great photo it's a scary photo um Shang
Chu holds the Guinness World Record for
pinning his head with 2,188 acupuncture
needles in
2013 talk about Hellraiser is there a
photo of that there is let me
grab
yeah talk about Hellraiser
2000 would you recommend that no no
that's that's so much blood rushing to
your head it just sounds like major
headache migraine is there yeah usually
you know you have a you have a problem
with your head or you have migraines we
might go down to your feet and kind of
bring your bring the energy down right
but would you recommend it for me uhhuh
if I do 2,000 whatever number his plus
one right could you get into the yeah is
that all you care about you want to do
that
now how many noodles do you
have oh wow that looks very beatable to
me I think I think I might have
that dude I'll sponsor it what do you
need I'll help I'll help however I can
it's so funny I mean like I hope that
the Guinness Book of World Records
people I I hope they don't do we have
contacts there Dan no I hope
they don't think that like all of my
complaining at a public level is like
really really like you know I'm just
having a laugh about it but well if they
take themselves seriously they should
rise above criticism for the records
right I uh I made a video on my YouTube
uh Channel called 10 undeniable world
records that Guinness gives me no credit
for ooh good and did you ever hear from
them still didn't hear from them
pieces of idiots morons losers but
but then again I've never actually made
contact with them right like uh to plan
anything out so maybe it makes sense to
do that I think usually have to do it in
front of them right for it to be
official yeah but I mean what about like
how how are they not going to give me
the record for barfing on television and
then film more than anyone else that you
think that's a
layup it's demonstrable I barfed on like
every episode of wild boys like almost
every episode of Jackass know how many
times you puked on camera oh my God like
a broadcast like around the world it
would be easy to determine and can you
puke readily could you puke right now
anymore no not anymore steo that
goldfish thing was insane bro
right what the new one yeah oh D caught
a lot of flag people were like dude
you're an animal lover like why are you
swallowing a goldfish and I'm like dude
come on the fish was unharmed right ah I
wasn't able to get it back up oh the
fish died yeah I wasn't able to get it
back up like I I I did eat
sushi you ate it well I swallowed it and
I couldn't get it back up well why
didn't you go back and finish the job
then um like it it got to a point where
I was like puking up blood and oh Jesus
I you know there were like specks of
blood and I was like look dude holy
bro that sadly that goldfish didn't make
it but that goldfish was Tiny had no
complex nervous system like really like
couldn't remember its way down into my
stomach in the first place like can we
please like Let It Go with the
goldfish already you know like it's not
a big deal plus I I'm no longer vegan
I've reintroduced Seafood into my diet I
eat Seafood because I think it's
healthy for me okay I ate a fish
get over it well so once you disel the
veganism then I think you're good I mean
cuz that's a pure that's you have to be
a pure right and and here's the thing
dude like I'm very much like an animal
rights guy right like I am absolutely
you can keep putting needles in me and
like like when when vegans are looking
at vegetarians and saying they're not
like doing it's just all this infighting
is super counterproductive can we not
collectively just move towards progress
and whatever represents progress for the
the individual and for the the
collective
like yeah like yeah dude we all all
of us animal people if you're not vegan
enough like who cares let's all just
make some progress in the right
direction right like adopt a dog you
know don't shop whatever like
whatever makes sense for you okay we're
going to start taking the needles
out okay so that's one two okay with
that yeah hell yeah I want them out of
me they're they're already out isn't
that amazing like not all of them and
then we put them in our little Sharps
container and they're official medical
waste are you surviving
yeah yeah uh so that's so then what what
was the um oh God I felt that one oh I
felt that one feel like you actually are
a little bit Cal like you're not talking
as fast your voice is a little lower
well my head is smashed into a tiny
hole that might have something didn't do
with that point but um so what was the
treatment goal here today what what we
were just doing a little relaxation
treatment and a little bit of lung
building your cheese you said you had a
cough okay you had a little lungy
deficiency so can I expect my my cough
to be reduced in severity I would say
that you would probably have to come in
and take it a little bit more serious
than just like one time that would be
like saying I'm going to take one
antibiotic if I have a serious infection
and I'm right okay fair enough you have
to take it like on a regular basis you
at least have to do a series of it right
or right you like one time of anything I
mean right and you at least have to get
it in your
wiener in the hole Steve or on the side
and I can't help you with that I don't
know if I don't know if I'm signing off
on the
hole okay by the way are all the needles
out all the needles are out and so I we
were going to maybe do some cupping are
you ready for
that this is going to suck way more than
the needles the cupping okay were we
doing the cups on your back dog Touch
where on my back where you're going to
do them so I'm going to do them right in
here and I'm actually because I know
that this is your first time so I'm
going to do it very gently right yeah do
them gently love deep tissue massage I
could go right I actually don't either
which is actually why I love cupping
because you just put them on for a few
minutes and you're done I don't have to
sit an hour I have yeah it's hard it's
kind of hard to do fire cupping on your
back though I mean I'm good but that's
it's kind of hard to do fire cupping on
your so you cued yourself but not on
your back right so I'm going to do right
here okay like right in this area and
then I feel like if your arms are back
it's much easier and then what's the I
really love this area right here too
because being at the computer all the
stress and tension I can see it so first
I'm going to put a little bit of and you
he's pretty tough you don't have to go
easy on him shut up Dan I don't know
what the is going on she's about to
light a bomb on my back or some I'm
going to's guy no I'm not don't listen
he's listen herbal bingay okay so it's
like all natural not toxic but it really
helps smells really good just kind of
put it in there and a little bit of oil
so what's the um story with the fire
cups fire cupping has been around for
maybe like a hundred years not as long
as oh God so this you have the 2000 chip
people just started doing this well yeah
I mean how are they supposed to know
that you could light a cotton ball and
throw it in a cup on someone back the
thing is like people that 2,000 years
ago had like magic and so I trust
them but then like some dude a
100 years ago was some idiot in like a
car or truck a buggy and a
horse and he's just lighting
on fire like what else were they
doing a 100 years ago they're using Le
they were blood leing
people you know what I mean like the
dudes 100 years ago were
idiots so just a little bit of fire oh
are you serious ready dude this is
going to burn stop it is not
stop oh it's not a see through so you
can't see the okay do you ever do it
with seethrough glass I do these are
ceramic so they they're a little bit
hotter so how are they doing it's okay
not so bad right no it's not that bad
okay can anybody oh I've seen ones
that's the sucking is crazy this one
feels small right right I I didn't want
to shock you yeah super cool you like
this the the sucking to be and
suck
that one bigger or is it the same size a
bit
bigger big suck action B suck okay dude
I'm bringing in a glass pint glass so
that we can actually see the fire inside
yeah just make sure it's sanit here oh
it will be wait you can oh you're going
to cup a a glass ah yeah you wanted it
stronger I didn't say that when did
I say that all right thank you there
how need like a big wow we're going to
need like a huge one for that
right what's happening no you're good
you're good wor it's not it doesn't feel
great up see how it pulls
[Music]
up I don't like anything happening right
now yeah there we go yeah dude I don't
like it at all there's no way to aren't
you glad I got a glass one I'm so glad
was here for this hey guys um dude
there's no way that this is
medicinal no way dude can we get a
couple more
glasses why are you doing more damn this
is how you do it
dude but a deep tissue massage okay so
don't leave the the cotton ball in there
huh no no no how do you take it out once
it's already in there though the the
cotton Ball's not in there oh how do you
take the cup off it just but I thought
you threw I can't see what's happening
so I have no
idea ah I hate
this okay yeah oh cool we've got a
couple
glass yo what the youo this isn't
like Bob Ross you don't get to paint
along you
guys everyone's taking their aggression
out on me I think Y what the was
that ow it's hot and it's pulling hard
it's a big suck he not pulling hard okay
don't tell me my subjective
reality ah that sucks that one sucks
more satisfying when you can see through
yeah I agree steo that's actually good
I'm glad I do want people to see through
it's really pulling up you're getting
that perp yeah the pine glass tomorrow
you're going to be so your back is going
to feel so relaxed it's relieves muscle
tension built up lactic acid is it even
sucking my muscle though it's just
sucking my skin skin oh it's pretty deep
in there okay so check this out I I've
got my my cup of water I'm going to
pound it so you can get another glass
okay hold on you don't need to hold on
steo we
have hold on we have other glasses okay
I can't do that one yeah you uh they
have to be sanitary the dog bowl yeah
the dog dish on the floor there
Ste yeah let's grab the dog
dish is your your husband here yes he is
he's watching this yeah he's jealous
right now he's whole thing is like I
never get any treatment what's his name
Bryant
Bryant what would happen do you think
are you jealous if if you if you if you
put the fire in the glass and then you
stuck it on a dude's wiener in his balls
oh God bro that wow I've never really
thought about that assuming that there's
some hair there it's kind of not going
to stick the hair's you yeah it has to
be on the skin like real so you got to
wax the dude yeah which that you know
that happens I would definitely I think
that would C potentially permanent
damage to the testies you sucked it in a
cup like that but I want to ask Brian
some questions Brian why aren't you not
getting treatments from your wife I get
reg oh you do Bri you get mad when he
doesn't get so wait why are you jealous
then how often do you get
treated okay hold on we're going mic
them up
with her husband is here and I want to I
want to learn about what goes on in the
lives of a
torture
artist I mean I got a lot more
treatments when uh she was in school for
sure
uh Briant how frequently do you get
treatment once a month that's
it you want more than that right oh of
course weekly would be great weekly such
a a bad wife and can and busy she's busy
and then I said make an appointment well
let me ask she makes me make an
appointment literally I'm like agent let
me ask you this what what was your name
again the acupuncturist oh Shandra so
Shandra is is there anything that he
could do for you that maybe you you'd
like to see more of that and it could be
an equal
exchange wow that's a very loaded
question like like for example if he
asked you to that's a that's a yes over
his his wiener and his balls God damn it
steo you're so fascinated with that yeah
it would be cool no I don't think I
don't think that's something he would
ask me to do yeah Ste I'll pass on that
thank
you I yeah there's he there's definitely
some things I could could entice me you
know cuz Equivalent Exchange I think is
you know give and take briyan I want to
hook you make sure you get hooked up he
he practices shiatsu he could give me a
shiatsu oh Brian you how often do you
does she get shatu yeah real right how
often do I get
shatu um she hasn't asked lately you
know okay hold the phone Bryant you
kidding you can't be you can't be you
know you got to be doing out the shiatsu
dude you got to be karate chopping and
elbowing and all that I
love it so what how much xatu would you
like to
get just once a week so it sounds like
the once a week even exchange right it
sounds like if you guys just put aside
like an hour once a week y'all can just
do a little you know professional
tradeoff yeah you're like a therapist
here it's
amazing I love it yeah so keep me
updated guys on your progress on that
well that Olivia now yes I'll let you
know Olivia will keep in touch with that
absolutely so you guys are both kind of
physical uh I don't what's the
discipline called but physical
treaters yeah I mean my husband's an
attorney but um oh he studied shiatsu a
long time ago oh okay so he's not a
practicing shiatsu no okay is so that
that was a little misleading then oh and
Brian you're a lawyer how often do you
work what your
hours uh uh 24/7 I just took time off
today yeah that's H ow what the
that's how we take them off no no no no
ow stop yo that that sucks so bad that
hurts like when you get waxed when I got
my hair waxed
off yo that sucks I hate that those were
all the glasses ow the glasses oh those
were the ones that sucked thanks
stea you're welcome bro what kind of law
do you do Briant God a medical
malpractice ooh spicy spicy and how do
you find clients do they just do you
have a reputation they just come to you
ow I actually work for the the
State oh you work for the
state so then so then are you for or
against medical
malpractice what's
happening like whose side are you on
yeah I think the question represent
doctors good for you oh wait no I don't
know okay maybe it's good I don't know
it depends it depends have you ever
heard a a doctor client you're like this
dude did it for
sure
so this is actually called Pera these
little red no comment on that pepp I
could barely hear that question I don't
know why oh I said have you ever had a a
doctor um client who you were defending
and you're like this guy definitely
did it for
sure I guess it depends on the facts
depends on the what the facts the facts
of oh that's not my okay all right
you're being
diplomatic you being diplomatic he
couldn't say anyways you know the
classic uh lawyer line is it depends it
depends good depends you've got some
good looking hickeys on your back bro
it's like you were attacked by an
octopus am done this is actually per you
technically are done all right wow I
mean I applaud you for giving it a try
and being open to finding balance Jesus
naturally there's no negative I got to
go back and look at what you definitely
need picture okay
yeah oh God wait you see yo that's
up right there okay ready nice
butt by the way that's your back that's
up it looks like a board game of like a
Connect 4 or
[Applause]
something Ste these those ones on the
side got me really good yeah this is
really lots of toxins you need to drink
more water the rder this
because this is you look dehydrated this
is like you pulled up so much I okay not
get some people barely get pink you're
kind of a little purple you need to
think half your body weight and ounces a
day given how awful Ethan's back looks
uhhuh is there any way that we can hire
your
[Laughter]
husband he'd be in a lot of
trouble oh man thank you for that of
course oh people are saying ask Shandra
about chiropractor Shandra does not like
the cracks I did I actually already
asked her about chiropra she says she's
not a fan that's too much for me that's
not it's too aggressive that's
goly good job bro that was very
entertaining thanks for participating in
that and thank you so much for coming
out and doing that uh and Olivia Bryant
back to my fabulous goddaughter you
can't be you can't hate me for that yeah
she's she's the best isn't
she she's the
best we got a good I I would like to go
home with this mug and give it to my guy
Eli there it is Eli it's
a
yeah a olive branch as they say yeah I
hope I didn't like hurt his feelings by
relating that well not with the mug yeah
the mug fixes everything so I feel my
definitely feel like minty but I think
that's from the
a little loer you seem more relaxed you
can tell your energy she's saying my
energy feels more relaxed yeah I feel
like it
does all right I'll be H I'll be honest
so when I'm gonna feel the effects of
this come to my office a real treatment
in Larchmont I'm in Hancock Park right
on the boulevard it's one of these days
come hi and see your dog wants to come
Alfredo Alfredo loves me Hi baby there
acupun for pets you don't absolutely how
do you keep them to stay still she hold
on she not are you m oh you're miked up
still okay good yeah you acupuncture
pets how do you and dogs they they'll
stay still and actually they oh I mean
this how could like this would be so
easy this poor guy's going be running
around with needles bouncing and I'm
like they don't even know probably you
just want to come home with me anyways
I'm taking your
dog no you're not is this Alfredo
everybody loves Alfredo kind of follows
you around
yeah he's my boy yeah we have two hus
he's dirty dirty the um groom are canell
twice oh he is
filthy I think he likes me
see okay well I'm just going to go
now well thank you guys of course thank
you so much thank you so much guys and
I'll I'll I'll keep I'll keep the feed
so this is tomorrow you're saying I
should feel the still the you're going
to sleep you're going to sleep great
tonight okay tomorrow you'll definitely
feel a release sometimes it's a little
sore you know but it all the purple
circles will go away trust me okay be
fine you're going to survive you're
going to survive I'm I'm I feel yeah
it's okay thank God you don't have to
have a baby in this lifetime right cuz
that that's true Amen to that we love
women for that don't we oh don't we Men
We love
women very good okay well um we've got
all kinds of great stuff to talk about
great I love it let's do it actually
can I get one of those like candy
coffees what are you drinking um yeah
I'll take another coffee was it a sweet
one uh it was like regular coffee and it
had the French vanilla creamer in it so
is it all come in the cup I don't know
okay cuz oh smells like it he got that
one right the French vanilla we just
added to his but another one get hook
him up with one of the crazy ones that I
like is it cold or hot it's hot oh good
yeah yeah it's just super sweet and
ridiculous like drink yeah good so okay
I mean we got so much good stuff to
get to dude um we barely scratched the
surface I know rosan uh well do we need
a debrief on the acupuncture I mean I
Heard lots of snickering and laughing
and kind of want to go back and see what
the I looked
like ready okay I'll wait till I you're
going to have to see uh what you looked
like with your face in the hole so so
what's your take on it I just did an AMA
yesterday how was the reception I think
it's pretty good I was trying to beat my
record which is 10,000 up votes what'
you get I don't know like it's sitting
somewhere uh like it's
this still going up what's it at but
last I checked the 7,000 something oh
cringe what do you mean I'm just kidding
I'm just doing a gag um yeah red I mean
I we have a huge community on Reddit I
like Reddit they're a little nutty the
people on Reddit in general yeah it's
they're a little bit a little bit mean
they're definitely can be absolutely
mean um I I just started my own
subreddit I should say A buddy of mine
started one for me should I go there I
mean you can it's called steo raw now
the rationale for this raw I had this uh
subscription thing like uh where you pay
for a monthly membership and this is
where I I can post anything with like
nudity or violence or whatever no
Community
guidelines oh God what is this oh
this is crazy bro and and then I
realized like that you can put all that
stuff on Reddit yeah you can do anything
on Reddit yeah so I shut down the the
paid subscription thing because I didn't
want to charge my fans for it and I've
got apparently I'm drinking your
water oh am I I think it'd be
okay
so so yeah cool ra I can't show it to
you guys because it's full of really
graphic here yeah um oh my God what
the hell I don't remember that or this
never aired no that that that I mean
that's mellow that's just a little thing
that's just people posting fun stuff
Jesus Christ dude yeah it's scary that
that snake would kill you was that a
venomous snake it's a rattlesnake Bro
that why would you do that because
dude because I'm dumb serious did you
have anti-venom on hand uh I don't know
maybe you don't remember perhaps yeah
looks like it was a long time ago so I
am I love Roseanne Bar she has some of
my favorite sound bites ever go ahead
Zach um she's got a podcast which I was
scheduled to do in the last couple days
but had to reschedule for some reason I
think she had a some type of emergency
oh okay why you got play the whole thing
Z I thought the was
white so funny it's so good when she got
cancelled there was
um there was a a staffer for like what
Clinton or Obama staffer or
something uh and she was saying
like comparing her to a gorilla or
something oh I remember that it was like
one particularly uh upsetting tweet that
just ruined everything ruined everything
yeah and so that but anyway she's back
and um she's she's serving us new sound
bites here it is oh it was former
White House adviser Valerie J Jarrett to
who which PR
uh let me whatever it doesn't matter can
I tell you that I was um invited to be
on the bill Mah podcast whatever he
calls it and uh and and I asked that
because I'm a clean and sober guy like
maybe he couldn't smoke weed the whole
time does he do that that was a deal
breaker for him oh my God what yeah like
I was so offended by that that's
literally like so mean yeah even like
Mike Tyson's hot boxing podcast like
they were like respectful enough to just
not smoke weed because I was there
that's so up I was so deeply
offended you should be that's so rude
yeah and and and uh who knows like um
you really can't go that long without
smoking bill you have a problem dude and
and and I wonder there's got to be
guests that he put down the weed for
like so why single me out I mean I don't
know I would guess yeah right I mean not
everybody wants to be around that so
yeah so on the record and I know this
probably isn't good a good idea like I'm
very offended by Bill we're mad at you
Bill you you addict and I'd be
happy to talk about it but like you
can't smoke weed the whole time
you co you better make this right bill
you anyway here
isanne I don't even know if you thought
it was racist it certainly was it was
not well I love her the was white
thank you I thought the was white she
said it again she's so oh my God but
that doesn't mean it isn't racist
because obviously she looks just like
the picture you're not going to
get yourself out of this by by
reiterating that and everybody's in
power got to be made fun of that's true
Mark Mark Mark Mark Mark that's not
the same as saying they look like a
monkey but okay you if you can't take
that's not speaking truth to
power she's doubling down on a losing
battle that's exactly what's happening
listen I was just speaking truth to
power when I called her a monkey joke
you you fascist that's how I feel
Bill and you know what I don't give a
what color your ass is if you ain't
doing right for your own people or
anybody's people in this country where
people are sleeping in the streets and
it Mak makes me sick then
you I don't give a about your
feelings you are offensive to me you
better take care of people living and
dying in these streets are you what are
you doing for them I always laugh when
people say that there's people dying in
the street it's like okay well have you
been down there with sandwiches like
what the are you doing lady you
know there was one time when my buddy
Eli same guy same guy love him uh years
ago he um took me down to um go give a
to go feed the Homeless on Thanksgiving
oh wow good guy you know yeah and and
and I I could not believe it that this
this give food to the homeless on
Thanksgiving operation had more people
trying to give food to the homeless than
there were homeless people trying to get
food yeah that is it's like so lopsided
for the love of God can we give food to
the homeless on any other day you know
oh it's the Thanksgiving everybody gets
too excited about it they're hungry
every day yeah for sure I was like dude
Eli this we were like waiting around for
an opportunity to like hop go here here
you go here I was like dude this makes
sense to me on any other day of the year
wowow interesting it's just it was such
Overkill that is
interesting um new angle of okay so have
you seen this guy PR Ethan's request oh
God there's all kinds of stuff here
uh I don't know if we should catch oh
here it is she said Muslim Brotherhood
and Planet of the Apes had a baby that's
speaking truth to
power I thought the was white she
says it's so nice there as a off
you know it's so nice the way she puts
it then
you uh per Ethan's request wrote some
code for the Matt R and Jordan Peterson
episode oh I saw someone crunch the
numbers on this
um we'll do this on uh there too much to
explain we'll do this next time but um
let's see have you seen this guy I
love him I've been obsessed with
him he's my guy I watch every video with
him he's got this crazy move and and
then it's from all different angles too
a new angle dropped hold on where's the
original uh let me see so like he has
he's super chill right and then all of
the sudden when it's time he busts out
this move so fat dude watch this he's
ready he's biting his time he's waiting
he knows he's the man every they're
doing some line dancing here look at
that boom dude what nobody's on his
level not even close not even
close so the reason I'm excited about
this is that it's a new angle and uh so
there's multiple angles coming out now
here is some I kind of it's like a JFK
grassy old situation for me so I was
thinking that we need to see it from two
different angles at once to get a full
perspective on uh the situation so
here's you guys
can dude how did two different angles of
this go viral do you know how crazy that
is um can you help me understand what
the recent developments in the JFK
assassination have been apparently the
case just only now in the last month or
so got blown wide open with new
information where people actually now
seem to have an idea what happened and I
think they're leaning towards the
government
did uh like make it happen I don't know
so I could be speaking out of turn I
remember there was like this
huge anticipation for a big like un
classifying of documents but from what I
recall there wasn't anything really
interesting in it I thought I saw it in
the news that it like just but I could
be wrong I mean is was there revelations
in that I don't know um I'll look into
it yeah but I guess the witness breaks
his silence which cause new questions uh
Paul
Landis um but yeah I'm looking into it
right now whenever I learn about JFK
assassination the one thing that always
blows my mind is the shot he made that
shot was so hard you mean the
Magic Bullet no the because that's the
problem with the whole theory is that
like for it to have been one shooter
like the bullet had to like go like the
Magic Bullet I think the Magic Bullet
got somewhat debunked I recall let me
see let me see if I can find information
about it um but but the shot he
definitely shot him in the dome from and
the shot when you see the where he was
in the tower and the moving car I mean
it's crazy the the shot was like
military guy or something yeah he was I
think he was a sniper or something son
of a okay okay chill Jimmy that's
not
cool uh was the Magic Bullet debunked in
JFK chat GPT how about that man bro I
love I live for it I die for it let's
see um the magic bolt Theory and uh blah
blah blah the the theory has been
subject to much debate and skepticism
with critics arguing that the Bull's
trajectory and the resulting wounds were
imp plausible however it's important to
note that the magic bullet theory has
not been definitely
debunked over the there's various
investigations including those using
modern forensic techniques and computer
simulations have reduced mixed results
so people are putting these in the
supercomputers I love it they can't
figure it out can we talk about AI for a
second sure deep fakes dude like when
when czy when can we expect the first
like really
consequential deep fake and how's it not
happened yet it may have already
happened oh well the thing okay so it
depends who right because because they
would the person who's the subject of it
would say that was AI now we might not
believe them but has it happened where
there's been a huge um
highlevel um dispute over if a video
footage was real or not I don't know but
but you make a very valid point that
it's going to be it's going to be on
both sides there's going to be like uh
fake stuff that causes a problem because
people think it's real and there's going
to be real stuff that people defend
themselves by saying it's scary it
really is the AI stuff is is nuts we we
just recorded a podcast which is yet to
be released uh with Gary V oh you got
Gary ve yeah he's great huh he's really
changed my life man and Gary ve was was
uh putting it in in such a an eloquent
and concise like digestible way that he
said always like video has been the
proof you know it's been the proof like
video didn't happen yeah and like now
we're entering into an age where video
will no longer be proof right like
nobody will be able to believe anything
that they see their own eyes it really
sucks because people already they call
it the Posta world or whatever it's kind
of cringe but like it's true to the
sense
that like people just believe and say
whatever they want and the people will
listen and believe anything no matter
the the facts and so introducing this uh
level of deception of qu of deception
and you know the the doubt yeah in
videos is going to be a pro it's going
to be bad it's going to be problem so
Gary V say you can go ahead and show
this in the background if you don't mind
Gary ve says that um what's gonna what's
Gonna Save the Day is blockchain
technology he did not tell you
that he he did oh my God he said
blockchain technology Gary ve you've got
to stop he's got to give that up man
he's got to stop with the blockchain
stuff well he said he says that
blockchain it it uh like can't be
altered and so um people it's going to
be a way of verifying humanness and and
the veracity of video footage it's the
first time that I had any interest in
blockchain so the theory is that you
upload a
video with blockchain ID yeah and then
so that the you that that's the source
yeah I mean okay okay all right he's
prettyy in on the Block I mean you could
well you can go to like New York Times
or something where videos are posted
originally and I mean that's trustworthy
if you go to like a major media I think
that that's fair too now what who
uploaded the
video I mean because the blockchain
stuff is can be anonymous yeah it's true
what what have your thoughts been on
cryptocurrency cryptocurrency is I
believe
uh
going to the Moon baby I think I think
it theoretically it's interest I don't
want to take the whole thing away from
it I think it is interesting technology
and it has been a an interesting Journey
that being said it's not something that
I would ever put my money in or that I
think is it a good investment for
anybody I think it's just serves as like
a giant money laundering as it is now
massive moneya laundering schemes huge
the basis of tons of prolific scams sure
and basic I don't think that it's it's
not facilitating anything but negative I
think at this moment I think that it's
intrinsic value is
for anonymous
transactions to facilitate criminal
activity yeah and that's about as as far
as the value of It Go in my opinion no
that's thank you exactly I feel the same
way and then like it it also uh is so um
counter to the interests of any
government of course that like it people
are like oh well it's going to really
take off when it when it gets uh you
know government approval but I'm like
why would the government approve
something never that is so counter to
its interests and it's it's counter to
all of our interests frankly like you
know it's good for buying drugs on the
internet that's what it was originally
for you go to uh the Silk Road
and buy heroin with it God is that a
great the Silk Road yeah that was
crazy he end he killed people the owner
that's what he went down for Yeah well
yeah he had did hits for sure what a nut
job it's insane it was like a a murder
For Hire kind of G every time anybody
ever tries to hire a hitman like 100% of
the time they're communicating with
undercover cops true right that's funny
dude I watch so much I mean listen it's
it's a legit problem where do we where
do you find someone to kill someone the
Silk Road
it's a the devil eating its own tail um
anyway so AI deep break I'm totally
aligned with you on on crypto I I think
but then again don't don't we wish that
we bought in Bitcoin at like 5,000 bucks
and sold it at 60,000 you could say that
about so many things you could say it
about Apple you could say it about
Microsoft you could say it about all
millions of different types of things
that's how investing works that's what
that's what the dream is right but
ultimately the people that are making
the massive profits on crypto people
think it's like this great equalizing
Force they're Bill these are the
billionaires the people that are making
all the money are the rich
who are like and by the way you can
influence the um price of crypto so easy
if you're super rich yeah pump if you're
an influencer yeah how have those crypto
uh uh all these going all these pump and
dump things dude that coffeezilla was
you know yeah you like I like it
he's great man yeah I really like copy
Zilla too shout out to copy Zilla and
and and when you say like when you see
these influencers like pumping up a coin
like buy it and they get all of their
their uh followers to buy a coin driving
up the price and then they instantly
sell it every time every time it it like
it is so nefarious it's it's just it's
straight up fraud yeah it's criminal and
it's like Logan Paul did the biggest
crypto scam with this crypto Zoo
and nobody cares I mean a
lot of people were angry at him but like
he didn't lose any fans look at this
this is New
Evidence I don't know if he was involved
or what but I'll tell you what that guy
could dodge a bullet with the way he
moves you know what I
mean yeah let's see what else we got
yeah what else do we have um new I have
an appointment to talk about my feelings
with uh with somebody in 15 minutes oh
you do wa you mean your therapist
no not uh it's a it's a one-on-one
feelings
sharing is it just a friend yeah it's a
friend oh okay you guys schedule time
that's cool you guys keep like keep an
eye on each other type of thing uh
that's kind of how it works yeah sponsor
or is that the right word that that that
would be the right word yeah so is he
your sponsor and do you do you look
after him or is the sponsor look after
the sponsor uh it's it's a relationship
where both people help each other I
would I would say yeah that's nice yeah
and who is this a guy you met randomly
in a meeting or is he a friend of
someone I've known him for many years
and he's also a recovery yeah wow yeah
that's a it seems like a special
relationship yeah we've been sober about
the same time yeah I'm I'm coming up on
16 years of surviv wow crazy it is
awesome crazy thank you being sober is
awesome I I've been sober for a long I
mean I I was never really addicted but I
like being sober really underrated I
feel like you know yeah tell me about it
all right so we got we got 15 minutes
get into the gold so here's the
chiropractors uh I love chiropractors
here's a compilation uh I guess some
people hate this so just tune out for
the next
minute but I was on Tik Tok and I saw
the best compilation ever and the
craziest thing is I couldn't tell if it
was a joke or not so this comes from the
page um hold on let me pull this up
Cairo
ASMR okay so so so this is chiropractor
ASMR and if you go to the page it seems
to be being genuine so here is
chiropracty
[Music]
[Applause]
ASMR this looks like straight Eastern
BL this is my favorite look at that
hold on look at this this man is is
literally doing like a meme where he
bends him in half look at this
this look at this yeah that does
not look good
man I love it dude it cracks me up I'm
sorry I know people don't like it but I
love it oh
God what is that he's trying to fold him
like a chair look at that
oh man
this is a fan channel for
ASMR ASMR is the Stu where you can fall
asleep yeah it's relaxing
sound that's
funny
wow it's
relaxing the sound is
relaxing
Jesus
[Applause]
that's another chiropractor ASMR
[Music]
sound Jesus man do you think that
anybody could accuse you for for for
including this and just sitting here you
know the way we're enjoying this clip
did there could you be lumped in with
Sniper Wolf uh I don't think so yeah you
don't think
so I mean we provide a ton of commentary
before and after there's a lot of
history of us talking about I mean what
we talk about chiropracty mainly to
debunk it I mean that's critical
commentary at its core so um no I don't
think so at all I don't I don't I think
you'd be hardpressed to
find do you think that people are just
ganging up on sniper she she's
definitely doing something wrong okay
and I think there's a widespread twitch
culture of
just stealing content lazy lazy content
it is frankly but you know it's a long
stream they don't know what to do for
that long period of time but ultimately
it's I don't think it's right it doesn't
send the right message it's not the
right precedent and uh well the real
problem too is Jack I don't know if you
followed the Jack film thing I did so
likeing the pro well that was insane the
problem was like YouTube is promoting
her and being like this is a great
Creator and I mean really that's the one
they care more about familyfriendly uh
than legality it's like they don't give
a about me because I say naughty
words and I may have also called I may
have said that Ben Shapiro should get
beeped okay that was in trouble I got I
got suspended for that oh wow I think I
missed that part I'll whisper it to
you yeah yeah well yeah we can leave
that
out um I didn't think it was offensive
at all for the record and I do not
apologize all right um so we got 10
minutes I am Jewish by the way okay just
so you know all right um what is this a
countdown what do you want to do I'm
just saying let's make these last 10
minutes count dude what I'm all right
quick
everybody maybe jump from the ceiling or
something if he has 10 minutes you want
to show him something special show
me check this cord
okay the pr all
right I've seen some prolapse wait what
does it mean you gave credit to the oh
that was earlier when he was mentioning
Sniper Wolf also you gave credit to the
account which she doesn't do usually you
said that this comes from this page but
she makes an effort to hide the account
she gets it from that's crazy that's a a
crazy thing yeah she hides credit and
stuff but not cool okay so there is an
Infamous video that's been going around
in our community called the we just
affectionately referred to it as the the
prolapse video pink sock it is pink sock
but it sounds like you're far
from new to observing such things uh
I've I have seen um pink sock footage
it's it's unbelievable holy look at
that he looks like a monkey yeah that's
the the Guinness World Record guy I
think it's
beatable um where is the clip it's in
now you can't show a prolapse video on
this stream no so you're just getting my
reaction to it exactly now the guy in
who's featured in is actually a friend
to the show Hunger FF he's a friend and
he's very talented at what he does um um
now how about Tom sigur's buddy um the
guy who shoves his own balls up his own
butt have you seen that I've heard about
it dude this guy's my buddy I've I've uh
become friends with him his name is
Pierce Paris and he's fantastic is he a
performer he is a uh a performer in uh
in gay porn okay he um is he specialized
in something
uh he specializes in all kinds of things
all right he's really really talented
he's an absolutely great guy nice yeah I
mean shout out to pierce Paris shout out
to PP and hunger is also such a sweet
gentle soul I mean he really is a great
guy so here it is this is um hunger FF
uh doing doing his best
work oh
wow
[Music]
that's two different people at the same
oh boy yeah they they they get together
it's a small community oh
boy that can't be healthy man so that's
hunger with the hairy ass he says he's
got like a he says he's fine I asked
like the doc oh my god dude oh it's hard
to watch even after all these times gosh
look how he grabs it you see how he
grabs it yeah I've just gotten a text
from prolapse to
prolapse you ever you probably haven't
seen that before have you look at that
steo yeah okay look at
it yeah I I'm I'm I'm enjoying it
uh oh God that's that is hunger yeah
yeah so there it is uh okay inspiring
video who are we calling I'm calling my
buddy Eli he's just texted me oh God Eli
is he watching what did he say he's he
uh he he he's um indicating that that
I've
uh publicly attacked him on his on his
favorite a I don't know this seems like
just put the camera on the prolapse when
he
answers when he answers that's looking
more like an if Eli it's okay man you
know what I mean we're we'll do
something great for you it'll be a
wholesome fun thing Eli is is
unavailable he just texted me right now
if he's genuinely upset then I guess I
understand why he wouldn't want to talk
on the here's what he said he wrote as
they say only the people who love us the
most can effectively make fun of us and
also own us on our favorite podcast in a
loving way to remind us okay that was I
can hear you so he's not upset yeah
that's good okay here there and he's in
my house working hi Eli what's up dude
thanks for
watching what's up guys yeah dude dude
I'm not sure I even want to meet you
after all the
I haven't I have not been been I'm
kidding I'm kidding it's all been live
so you've seen it anyway thanks for
thanks for he's at my house working for
me he damn well better not have been
watching this is that right know I'm
here with Paul we're editing Steve Steve
steo Empire Richard Dangler headquarters
right here there it is but Ethan it's
it's it's lovely to see your face see
the crew and uh dude
um I uh this even more Awkward than I
would have imagined it being me bringing
him here I'm listening I'm listening go
on well dude I just want to say to
anyone who ever doubts that Steve is the
real deal he is the man and uh and I owe
so much of my life to this guy so oh
that's well Eli and I have a a
relationship where we share our feelings
with each other too that's good I see I
noticed you do that a lot and I think
that's very healthy yeah yeah I have a
lot of feelings men yeah but uh but yeah
man uh thanks for letting me call in
Steve I don't want to make this more
awkward but uh you're good it's not that
awkward you know what it's really not
that we should wrap it up it's not that
awkward Eli I I uh I'm coming home with
the mug for you show the prap do you
want to see the prolapse Eli yeah yeah D
never seen all right well can we get a
shot at least for the audience can f uh
excuse me have to point yeah that's
perfect oh yeah ab's going to get a
closeup okay good here you go Eli
private uh viewing party here it is Eli
from steo
Studio wait what happened the
oh ah you can see the ref oh God I
didn't show anything
luckily all I didn't open it yet wait so
but can we show him or not here coming
and I got it on a different all right I
can see it you can zoom in Ian do a
little lower your camera lower it so
it's behind the laptop it is behind the
oh okay so lower here I can hold it put
your thumb here so much effort you see
what I'm talking about the in the bottom
corner is what the camera the selfie
camera covering that we're covering that
exactly about well he can't see if
you're covering the camera just cover
the C the screen the feed the feed of
the selfie P that's in the bottom corner
cover that with your thumb Eli you're
derailing my
dud yeah God damn except not even dying
see that nasty it's not your fault um
okay here it
is go all right go ahead
hunger yeah funger
FF oh my God
[Music]
bro dude it's hairy
too just pull it out oh all right does
it
tickle
dude that's that's pretty
hot that gets me it's like carneia
[Music]
bro Steve are you good with this um why
would I not be good with this
bro like why would why would I have a
problem with this Eli why would you have
a problem with this bro all right Eli
thank you it's been a pleasure to check
it out like wow if given wow
Pria and I love Paul and I most
especially Love Steve and then uh
slightly below that Ethan Klein thank
you guys okay fair that yeah yeah now
now uh Eli in in the final analysis if
given a choice between an awkward
handshake maybe a photo with Eli or be
actually on your favorite podcast I
think you came out on top
dog absolutely yeah thanks for watching
though for real appreciate that buddy
yeah and dude there's how many people
are are watching
now says 40,000 40,000 people watch God
that nobody saw that in the Stream
though and that be the end of my career
and I also want to say good this has
been a joy nice to see you too long we
got to get together feel like we should
we should we should do this even more
there's so much we could get into I
agree yeah we have fun yeah we have
everybody go to
sto.com and support my bucket list I
guarantee you you will not be
disappointed there it is yeah all right
go go go do a good
feelings situation and all right dude I
love you all man bye dude love you too
Eli bye dudes all
right is
theine you heard
this said that's him singing for
real oh thanks you can just put him yeah
you're good you just put
him thanks
[Music]
bro this is the best ambient music
yeah that's steo ladies and gentlemen
the one and
only and um and also combined with
acupuncture I mean a treat for the
century and she make sure she sends me
the invoice what an episode I want to
pay her for her work what an episode I
mean so the debrief on the on the
acupuncture you're feeling great right
yeah how do you feel I didn't like
honestly the cupping it might surprise
you it made me
less the needles made me more
uncomfortable really you could feel that
I don't know what everyone says and
then she started bending it I was like
lady stop the I'm with you I would do
the cupping I would not do the the
needles dude I do not like cupping she
spun spun the needle around in your
brain why do that she like Twisted it
like that was really do tune it tune the
brain you're tuning my brain lady yeah
it's like a guitar string so yeah I
don't know it's interesting I guess I I
personally
uh she says I feel I look more calm so I
guess she did say I guess I
I feel feel this all right we got so
much stuff to get to guys we got a new
wheelchair
video hey check it
out oh this is an old classic I've seen
this we probably watched this on the
show years ago uh it's hard to find ones
that we haven't seen is this one this
one's super violent this one is actually
can we I don't know this one's super
violent this one's kind of yeah
he falls like really high he like knocks
over this guy's ladder somebody's on
that ladder oh he falls like 20t he
falls on his back too I think he needs
acupuncture man why did he do that this
guy's just shaking the ladder
I'm not going to show the fall but like
here take off the screen again look at
this this madness all right I'm not
going to watch it yeah no if you haven't
seen fire GTA 6 trailer just dropped mhm
I'm so excited what I don't think I can
watch it no probably not definitely not
oh the music well they're going to claim
the whole trailer probably there's so I
love that man let's claim our
promotional trailer that is just
legendary highlevel
marketing um Ador me is using me and
Olivia in a sound H
another another company is trying to get
me paid let's see do you you guys know
what adormi is have you heard of that
before nope adormi no it looks like some
kind of underwear
lingerie it looks nice it does okay so
maybe we can part of the settlement will
be that they'll just send whatever we
want oh it describes itself
as fun and sexy lingerie for all sizes
and styles sick so here it is
um here it
is biolog hi girl hey girl I see
you that's in an ad it's like an actual
ad so thank you to everyone who sent me
this cuz Daddy's about to get paid I can
smell the money Adore Me pay me more
like thank
you that High girl sound is doing pretty
well though I think on Tik Tok think so
it's going around right that was from
the one where you guys swapped uh oh and
I can see you from all the way up there
can we pull up the Tik Tok sound page
I'm curious how the legs on that one uh
oh okay let me see Jeremy boring if five
million
wait what who's Jeremy
boring uh that's the daily wire dude
isn't
it um I don't recognize him I don't know
who's this guy I don't know who the
is yeah Jeremy boring is the the daily
wire guy oh he's quoting him got it
what's this yeah the CEO the CEO yeah
yeah okay let's hear what he has to say
I'm sure he's
enlightened that's the dude who just
made the trans athlete extravagant lady
baller lady Ballers hottest movie of the
year all right let's listen go ahead
Jeremy spit oh Tim cast okay good oh you
know it's
good here's the
problem the problem is that anonymity on
the internet allows for the ghettoizing
of beliefs that are not approved by the
regime so a lot of people will say well
I have to be I have to be anonymous on
the internet because my boss finds out
that I've got these views they'll fire
me but you're only in the position where
your boss could fire you for finding out
about those views because you've allowed
those views to be completely ghettoised
through anonymity online what does he
mean by that ghettoized just being
racist uh ghetto well ghettoized in the
sense that they're like confined to a
certain corner of the internet is that
what he means I I'm
I'm working on processing what he's
saying H even though that's what ghetto
is I've rarely I don't think I've ever
heard of used no definitely not he's all
right go on Jeremy I'm I'm listening if
uh I
if five million people came out today
and said uh the
nword I'm not recommending it but no one
would ever get fired for saying the NW
again what oh these dudes that's a
strange thought
experiment yeah how do you know that
wait wait I need I need to hear him
elaborate on this wait how would you how
do you know what would happen the five
million Man nword mark
he a
he's a civil rights Pioneer for
the nword for white people saying the n
word we're taking it back oh my God
Jerry boring said that's our
word the r word is our
word holy okay interesting said uh
the
n-word I'm not recommending it but no
one would ever get fired for saying the
n-w word again
would able to you wouldn't be able to
you would have brought that to you would
have brought that to a conclusion that
little absurdity in our culture uh would
be okay so oh that absurdity that you
can't say the n-word yeah that's absurd
say it then exactly why you saying that
he needs five million people to do it
with
him conclusion that little absurdity in
our culture uh would be brought to an
end the ghettoizing of our beliefs
allows for the punishment of anyone who
steps outside of the ghetto yeah so if
oh you're right he's talking about a
confined space I guess he feels he's in
a ghetto yeah he's been ghettoized cuz
he can't say the N word he can't step
outside the ghetto and say the
NW but you're the CEO you could do it oh
say it bro say it Jeremy Jeremy say it
wow that's that's crazy nah bro
I don't like jermany either nobody's
stopping you excuse me sorry I could not
stop coughing today man dude I have this
cough that's I'm that was disgusting I'm
sorry you had to see that Olivia no I
thought it was funnyit what happen not
funny it was funny I coughed out I don't
want to talk about it we don't oh you
got a just fle a f situation giblet came
flying out but I I don't know what's
going on it's just there's tons of fluid
in my lungs man it's juicy like well I
was I was pretty rough this weekend
today I'm mostly better but I'm still
very clogged up but not covid people you
can zoom in on that took one this
morning right as I got here it's just
plain old regular cold so the
uh the vaccine
Works he doesn't have actually just got
my booster like a month ago um so I was
going to be really pissed if it
was Co but it's all good uh go on Jeremy
tell tell me
more saying what you believe they can
fire you but if we all just had our
names on and we're saying the things
that we
you
might that we would have more culturales
if we didn't have online because the
online anonymity also allows us to
become more radicalized in ways that Pro
left and right in ways that probably
aren't ultimately good you know what
actually first of all the acid reflux
someone said yeah but
probably first of all the analogy and
examples you used is bananas to get to
that however I don't ha hate the idea of
like on Twitter and stuff people have to
verify their IDs because I do think that
there's people would not be in such
nasty little freaks on social
media if you know who they were and uh I
think it would be a more I don't know
what do you think is that crazy I mean I
don't know not not in the whole how can
you enforce ID on the whole internet
that's not what I'm in favor of not like
oh I have to give uh Comcast my ID to
get internet not like that that's that's
weird a lot of countries do do that I
think really I could be wrong but I
think in South Korea everybody your your
real ID is attached to your internet
account
correctly sure they they have like crazy
cyber bowling there where like
people are like it's a hug problem I
could be misremembering this but I
thought uh I thought I remember hearing
about that um I think you're right it's
a cyberbullying thing and so um South
Korea turn and so I don't hate the idea
of like social media where people are
doing these kinds of things oh yeah
South Korea was the first country to put
an internet real name system into
practice since
uh uh5 Korean web oh so it's not
necessarily
everything because they say 35 Korean
websites have implemented name
registration yeah but I don't I don't
know where the 5 Million Man nword March
came from and all that you
know that's
weird but go on
Jeremy we love that a very insightful
fruitful conversation over at timcast
Tim everyone should have nukes
cast and we love that don't we oh my god
um what do we got
here wow moment hold on bro that's not
the March you think it is I believe an
individual citizen in this country has a
right to own a nuclear warhead hold on
Jeremy that's not the right March dude
somebody's got to pull him out of there
man it's going to get
ugly not the time or place for that kind
of
language uh nowh no time nowhere is the
time for that language
um we got another wheelchair one uh no
not this one mobility video in a casino
oh I saw this this guy is awesome man
this is just
fruitful Ingenuity man look at him go
he's playing all of them oh yeah this
guy
rocks and that's how you
game that guy's in so deep he needs to
play Four machines at
once he actually can walk he just brings
it for the can gamble
yeah well good luck to you sir I hope
you're get big Innings I hope he's still
going rumor is he's still going today
yeah
still in a
loop the Vicious
Cycle oh Colleen's new content is a
little weird let's see oh I saw this
yeah I don't know okay first of
all the photoshopping of this makes it
seem worse mhm than it is I'd rather
look at it without the head because the
head feels more vulgar I I didn't I
didn't find this one to be that
interesting frankly she had like a
pretty big pants on underneath I don't
know the context of it she was bent over
like grabbing rocks and she was showing
the camera that she had shorts on yeah I
I don't think it's a big deal honestly
God I love her I'll give her the pass on
that one Colleen she's done far worse
absolutely oh I've been looking forward
to this big Nick oh is preaching and
casting out
demons how fun is that hell yeah um here
he is the
I got to say obviously he was going
down a really effed up weird path um but
on the other hand I do love his new
content so I don't know if he has a p if
he has a Renaissance he has a patreon or
something you know a big Nick
Renaissance right now so let's see uh
after the event demons started to
manifest during the altar call oh
no preaching Jesus to thousands and
casting out demons with Richard Lorenzo
Jr Dallas
Revival we captur it on video it's muted
on YouTube oh he wait hold on by what
power vested in him does he have the
authority to cast out demons now Jesus
don't you have to be ordained or
something no you can no you can just be
anyone Jesus be talking to him he says
it you can be anyone and just be casting
out demons like what that's just I feel
like you need credentials at least I
mean he's got credentials big
Nick Jesus he's worked his way up the uh
the ladder corate ladder right let's see
what he's
got look sounds fun
there you guys heard this one they go
like in 1930 a giant pit open in the
earth and the sounds from hell were
heard yeah it sounds just like this yeah
it does
come out right now in the name of Jesus
come out right now in Jesus name come
out right now in the name of Jesus
Spirit of rection out out in Jesus name
spirit in Jesus name now in the name of
Jesus of rection he doesn't puke does he
no okay which I don't want to see that I
have thoughts on
that he's trying he's gagging he's
watering he's trying he really wants to
get go
back come on right now in the name of so
is Nick's power level too low that he
can't get him to I'm not sure if the
problem is the demon is too high of a
level demon or you like you said if
Nick's too power level is too low or
it's might just be a skill issue to be I
think it's a skill issue because if he
was strong enough that guy would have
puked immediately you look at Exorcist
she like pukes like and Big Time pukes
come out right now in the name of Jesus
come and he's trying too it looks like
he's got his finger someone's got a
finger in his he's watering I mean big
Nick you could have done better with
this one come out right now you posted
this bro come out right now and Jesus
after this fat
fail all the way out in Jesus name all
the way out all the way out a looks so
fun there I want to be
there how is it that like these people
don't realize they did a whole 180 and
they're in hell they they're in hell
this is what hell sounds like right this
is what happens
there you are in Hell the speaking in
tongue things is the most demonic
ever I was shocked the first time I saw
that CU I thought it was like
satanic letting spirits take you and
doing weird languages that's Satan
that's Satan's business well
maybe Jesus
name the way out in Jesus name he's not
this poor guy leave him alone all the
way out in Jesus name all the way out in
Jesus name come out of them right now in
Jesus name all the way out clean
yourself out clean yourself out in Jesus
name every single one of you out out out
in Jesus name in Jesus name Luke 10:19
come out right now in the name of
Jesus God bless you man God
bless that's it thanks for that bro do I
tip you or what the demon is still in
there it did not come out come out right
now in the name of Jesus come out right
now in the name of Jesus yeah why aren't
we more worried dude we need we need
someone else the demon still in there
bro
unsuccessful that's fun that's where
they want the Christians they say that's
where we want to be the gagging
hellscape every single one of you out W
by so should I keep watching
this you the next time stamp so uh Nick
always prays before energy drink why cuz
he doesn't want to die yeah for real he
doesn't know what's in it well was a
long day yesterday so that's so awesome
so his theory is probably that he Jesus
is protecting keeping his energy drinks
coach Jesus could turn red bull to Wine
true if not Jesus then who Jud me okay
so I just got the energy drink now what
I like to do with these energy drinks is
I like to pray over them cuz you never
know what chemicals that they're really
putting in these shout out to this guy
in the back by the way don't know who
that guy is but uh I pray Lord in Jesus
name that you would bless this drink and
rebuke any harmful chemical in it in the
name of Jesus all right let's try it out
does God hold on does God rebuke harmful
chemicals that's awesome that feels
Petty to me like you shouldn't be
wasting God's time with that you know
what I mean like got he's busy guys he's
got a lot going on and it's like oh I
wanted to drink this energy drink but
maybe it's bad for me God will you help
me it's like get over it God there is
about a on10th a part per million of red
seven in this could you please cast that
out and I'm choosing to drink it I want
the drink don't get me wrong right but
Jesus if we could just like team up on
this God would tell him drink gamer Subs
true so true that's the holy drink right
there a holy water Amen brother yep not
bad we just got to the house right now
Bri and so that's that yeah and then
there's one more at the end there's a
big Nick checkin he performs another
Exorcist
man if I was going for an exorcist
though I would go to a professional
right I would go to this dude who has
the collar and all the whole thing shows
up under Catholic right now for
Christmas and like you need you need
holy water and right ropes I think
you need to rope tie them to a bed why
you in a kidy pool man is he just doing
a baptism yeah yeah okay I think I yeah
okay that's fine yeah I assume so yeah
that's that's fine okay I baptized Chris
right now father God in the name of the
Father the Son and the Holy Spirit die
with Christ rise with Christ amen bro we
out here bro Soul's getting saved take
that Satan dirty devil take that demons
diss track on these demons right now
bro oh my
God no demons
oh my
Lord that made me cringe so
hard big up demons bumba CL
demons dude I have this one song stuck
in my head the m dot guy I love him so
much what to give me head yes I love him
then wait is that the the white British
guy that was doing that yeah big bumba
clut said she want to give me a head
then he
goes then it says something about do the
and the py turn red and gymnastics
now the
dead such a baller wow anyway big Nick
he left the event but he felt the Holy
Ghost some spiritual presence pulling
him
[Music]
back right now Inus i' heard you by fire
right a girl came up to me and asked for
prayer and as soon as I prayed demons
started to manif are following him
around if demons are manifesting doesn't
that mean that he's the one putting them
there I what the didn't want to be
the one to say bro you're putting if
what you wrote is true you're putting
the demons in them man that's
sick is Big Nick a little demon he's
just like
manifesting a big demon no I don't mean
his size yeah I know but he's big like
he's he's a little you little devil like
that right you little devil
I'm not making fun of his size for the
record got it if I was I would take
different roots with it y it was a turn
of phrase like an imp or something I
don't know yeah okay now you're pushing
well I'm not I'm just saying
theoretically an imp would be funny
image I don't know though
small I just
realiz what did you Z that's up
bro Jesus Christ you know like what what
the
good to be back guys oh my God I
love you D oh that's
yeah I mean I don't know but
sorry I didn't mean to do that big demon
he's a big demon Sor sorry sorry sorry
sorry sorry
sry open your eyes open your eyes open
your eyes look at me obey the authority
of Jesus Christ I was not expecting to
do this but someone so I did not have my
camera but someone else recorded on
their phone sure
dude leave right now in Jesus name look
at me obey the auth of Jesus Christ
right now all the way out out out in
Jesus name out get out of her right now
in Jesus name out out in Jesus name
leave right now leave right now leave
right now her friend is probably
stealing his camera right
now name I Pur You by fire right now in
Jesus name leave right now in the name
of Jesus you have to go Jess get out of
her get out of her J every Spirit of
trauma
[Music]
every Like These Guys these people would
benefit from uh sto's emotional uh
support group or something yeah dude
let's let's talk about it you know
screaming and vomiting I guess it can be
cathartic you know to have a spiritual
Purge but I think we should talk about
it more than that you know you're out
you're gone it is finished I'm here
right now with deler he he
keeps cutting this short I don't get it
so right do they are they puked out are
they do they come out different ways I
mean you need some consistency here yeah
I don't I don't get it all right let's
hear what she has to say Melissa this is
the aftermath of it I am emotional emal
still crying still processing tell us
what just happened right now I got
delivered I I was praying and I kept
asking God to deliver me and I would
pray with three other people I was
trying to speak in tongues I couldn't do
it maybe they're all drinking that
energy drink and that's making them
vomit oh they didn't pray on it no they
didn't it's got some weird
in it true and I just kept trying and
trying and I was about to give up but
then Nick was sitting in my seat and so
I asked him if he could pray for me and
he prayed for me and I was not expecting
that to happen at all but I'm thankful
that God delivered me amen I wasn't
expecting it what does that mean God
delivered her what is she a
Pizza 30 minute guarantee on that
or what for
real I guess nobody knows I'm curious
what does it mean to be
delivered uh delivered in the The Eyes
Of God basically she sees the light he
because when he was talking about going
to this event he said that the other
priest that was there was going to teach
him how to do deliverance and then he
began this uh Escapade deliver uh in
Christianity Deliverance Ministry refers
to groups that perform practices to
cleanse people of demons and evil
spirits these groups attribute certain
people's physical psychological
spiritual and emotional problems to the
activities of these evil spirits in
their lives uh the doctrines and
practices of these Ministries are not
accepted by all
Christians right I guess that's probably
important to point
out that's true we love the Christian we
kid them because we love them we do love
the Christians they're great some of the
best people I know we love you the worst
you're very special um oh yeah here I
got the lyrics so I'm going to do this
again for you guys B bubble clut split
for busting a me head hot sexy girl yes
she want to give me head when my
turned red gymnastics now
the is
dead I love him he's he he's Liv you say
his name was again it's like M do
something M.R M.R yeah I follow him I
frankly am I think I might be a
fan and there's so many clips of him
doing um that line like I've seen people
on the street he does it for their Tik
toks he seems super nice about it too
like not snobby at all oh it's spelled
out
M.R gotta
gocha here let's let's check his insta I
saw him do it at the subway with like a
piano and all that he's down to do it
anywhere I like that he's not like too
he's not too cool you know what I mean
yeah
here let's see he's he's at the damn
he's at the Christmas uhe fr the
Christmas floaty bouncy
party oh does it get claimed man like
goes it might it might uh we haven't
checked it soever so that's my boy I do
love him well we got to check it because
I want to hear that
frequently okay I'll check
it I'll check it go ahead with the audio
basically the Lord highlighted her in
the spirit to me and so as I was praying
for her I felt her shaken and I knew
that there was a demon in there I saw
her highlighted in the spirit that she
was dealing with the spirit of doubt I'm
here right now with Frank Frank God
bless you man yesterday you were here
right yes sir the altar all
right that's that's the gist there's
nothing wrong with it I mean they're
they're minding their own frankly there
isn't they're minding their own business
they're doing their own thing and that's
be and you know what I mean then that's
great they're not trying to they're not
trying to influence anyone at least not
this event I think Nick would probably
Outlaw a lot of horrible if he if
he was imp God or whatever
however um come out right now in the
name of Jesus A lot of them are probably
cool I'm trying to give more grace to
the uh Christians because we love
them here's um this really makes you
think
man speaking of big Nick
uh dude look at the view
on Shing fortnite 3,000
views hope
200,000 a random music video of big Nick
worshipping a book that some random guy
wrote thousands yearo has 210,000 K
views meanwhile a music video about liby
dun getting rised up by baby grank has
less than 4,000 views this speaks
volumes about our society today
sh sake
that's dude I was devastated when I
learned
that someone's saying it's not delivery
oh it's demons oh that's good it's a
Douro
memey I am delivered it's the demon mhm
nice y'all with the uh
dejour shit's so good bro it is I don't
remember if it was good or
not it's not as good as ordering pizza
though right I ordered a Domino's a
couple weeks ago it was trash oh it was
really it was really upsetting H yeah so
you would have had a Douro Pizza on that
day yeah f they me
dude yeah so we talked to sta we had a
fun time we got eel pit we've got Tick
Tock alpab bro oh H bomber guys new
video which I didn't finish the write up
on that though so it's not that
segment's not really ready um how long
have we been going today I mean it's
4:30 uh we're coming up on three hours
okay which isn't too bad it's good it's
not bad I do I do want to hit three
hours how much time we got well I'm
checking uh your boy's uh video right
now if you want to give me one more
second and then maybe we can watch
that 245 oh yeah please we're just
checking on m. M.R seeing if we get a
claim here just another
moment let's see I'm sorry that you got
a bad dominoes uh Zach but I'm GNA stand
up for Domino's right now I I think it's
better than the other like fast food
pizza places I'd agree with that I take
it over Papa and uh and Pizza Hut
personally why don't you just order from
like a like a restaurant that's how I
sometimes I do sometimes I do I guess
it's just easier I don't know we usually
do that but you know sometimes you're in
the mood for something like trashy you
know I'll be honest a lot of times I
order from these uh like I don't mom and
pop or whatever I don't know some of
them are probably
Woodfire a Woodfire is good I I don't
know if there is any around here best
pizza in the world bronis hands down
Baron you ever had it no there's one in
Tio there's one in Van eyes baronies or
perronis baronies Baron I don't know
that one well a lot of times I get from
these stores it's kind of not good I got
to say I'm missing the Swedish Pizza a
lot I'm not liking the I'm not liking
the fast food pizza here it's I what
you're talking
gross ass flaf pizza or whatever
I heal upates or Keb Pizza you guys want
Health updates for your health I
did I tell you guys I pooped in a box to
get it tested no no you haven't
mentioned
that so I did a follow-up blood test on
all the Rheumatology the um and then
what was the other one the uh
hematology
my two
boys my dogs I dab them up my dogs uh so
the blood the thing is also I to I told
my primary doctor about this horrible
egg burp situation I'm having because I
was like this I don't know if this is
normal
man um so I pooped in a box and I'm so
glad that I could poop in the office
because they're you they're like bring
it home poop put it in ice and it needs
to be returned in 2 hours yeah
so I'm so glad I did it while I
was there I thought I my pants nasty
right so my I did have a poop situation
wait so did you poop all the poop in the
box or just a little
bit it's so gross they give you
a tray yeah you in it and then they
give you a wood stick to scoop a sample
out okay it's so mean I get it that's
not too power yeah I mean it's human
but it's gross it's really gross
and then
she um they give you a big ass Hazmat
bag to put everything in at the end and
I tied it up I tried to get the air out
so it doesn't wasn't puff you but I tied
it up and I brought it back as
instructed and then she threw it in a
little it just like a tiny stupid silly
little trash can and it was too puffed
up and went it closed Clos had to pop it
someone would have to pop it someone was
going to have to pop oh my God that's
awesome that
oh my God pretty funny huh oh that is so
good yeah wow um so here let's see we
got
some we got some lab
tests the C so there was something
elevated it was the
Cal
Pro Cal Pro
calpro cpro
stin was
elevated does that mean you got lupus it
actually uh I don't think it's a lupus
indicator but it might be a inflammatory
bowel disease indicator so
poopus got him
poopus nice but it the the value wasn't
super elevated it was moderately
elevated
75 what's the the normal range is up to
50 h new disease
unlocked yeah I mean I hope not because
I mean if it's positive it would if yeah
it would mean I had like Crohn's or UL
uler of colitis something like that yeah
which my mom has ulcerate of colitis I'm
saying it
right these nuts high levels of Cal praa
indicate yeah that's basically what you
just bacterial or parasitical infections
oh why' you have to do they one with
cancer bro why' you have to do that
coloral cancer or certain diseases you
could have took that
out just do my job no I'm kidding I
think the ccer values would be like
super crazy El I hope you get ass cancer
and die you son of a I'll cut your
throat I'll come to your house and kill
your children dude chill bro what the
hell is wrong with that guy give me $200
so anyway he says hi Ethan the feal test
was found to be mildly
elevated feal matter this is a test to
look for signs of inflammation in the
bowels the fact that it was abnormal
doesn't mean you have inflammatory bowel
disease but it also doesn't rule it out
thankfully your level was not
significantly elevated I'll check with
the uh rheumatologist and then he texted
with the rheumatologist you guys and I
just got an email a message from him he
said we recommend that you come back in
four weeks and in the box
again oh no he says repeat this test in
four weeks and if it's still elevated we
would proceed with a
colonoscopy oh no oh
boy oh no darn
it oh maybe you'll like
it clear you out so true clean out the
pipes yeah I've ordered the test again
please make a reminder to get this done
in a month can you remind me Lena
Lena I need to in the Box again in
a month this was my ass yes you got
that sorry what was that I need to go
in a box again in a month oh okay
to do got
what yeah I'll arrange he said he
ordered it he just says just remember to
do
it
yeah my ass the doctor's um sister is
apparently a
fan and I say I said if that's true she
probably knows more about my medical
history than you do yeah true
so shout out girl wait so that also
means you can't start trash talking this
doctor I love him okay good I would
never say anything bad about them I love
my doctors they're all super cool no
okay no yeah ever since I switched to
the um I'm not even going to say the
group that'd be dumb I give it what I
switched uh health insurance and I was
with
uh
Kaiser but um the new one is I'm really
happy happy with I mean Kaiser's there's
pros and cons it's super convenient
because everything's right there mhm but
they take forever to do it's
annoying as are you guys happy with
the
Kaiser I never had health insurance so
I'd love it yeah I know that feeling
yeah yeah I haven't had any issues I've
only gone a handful of times but it's
always I've always been able to get an
appointment pretty quickly and I get my
test results back in a day or two so no
complaints okay but I'm sure your
mileage will vary one like right down
the street from my house so it's like
super convenient okay cool love that I
was going to say that I could put you
guys on whatever I'm on but if Kaiser I
mean Kaiser's good I don't want to speak
for everybody
but I personally haven't had if anyone
hates Kaiser tell me no we I I love it
and we have the best plan available so
thank you for that hell yeah thank how
work if I go to the hospital do I say I
have insurance you got to go to a Kaiser
facility oh or I think they have I think
that there's probably other hospitals in
the network right right right okay I
mean knock on wood God bless nothing
serious has happened to me but if I have
like a flu or something they're they're
good their T do is really good too oh
good oh that's awesome yeah good I'm
glad yeah but like all these tests I'm
doing and all I mean it's all like a lot
and it's intense and to be fair I'm not
like the most if it's a triage I'm
probably not topof the line so I feel
like they wouldn't be able to do all
this stuff for me right at least not
over the with some level
of did you know that uh I recently
learned this and I'm looking it up on
Wikipedia real quick to make sure I'm
remembering this correctly but Kaiser
actually started as like a ship building
company or some it's a weird
transition yeah I think it was like here
I'm trying to
find it was founded by industrialist
Henry J Kaiser and yeah uh his company
was one who built the Hoover Dam and
Kaiser shipyards who built the Liberty
ship how they make that s too I guess
they started he probably started he
probably had a ship Builder's Mallet and
he was doing a
chiropra no I think it started as a a
health he gave health insurance to his
employees he hired a doctor yeah and
like started it that way and now it's
transitioned that it's like its own huge
thing but yeah it it all began is they
build ships Kaiser willham or uh
the Kaiser role Kaiser wilheim yeah the
the the late uh king of Germany yeah I
was always under the impression no
relation to the Kaisers of the 19th
century what about the Prussia uh
someone said I think what I am on is
Blue Cross someone said yeah it's like
but Blue Cross
Shield I think so they're the best so
they the so then I went to a so good it
is so good and and then so I went from
that to oh Blue Cross Anthem what is is
that the is that different I think it's
just really I think they just keep
merging and how many Blue Cross
divisions do we have well anyway they
don't they through their Network I've
gone to a Health Organization that's
really good thank you cool very cool
good for you great thank you so much
thank you um
so we're all good on your boy yeah
so if you wanted to pull that back up
here here's his oh let's do this and I
I'll thank our donos and stuff okay
great um can you link me
yeah you
be get out this feeling forever live
oh my God oh my goodness what the
what did you do to me you got cued
bro that's that's what it is what the
that's art you're bruised up bris
looks like a bunch of PR the okay I like
it Picasso that's
crazy that's crazy right there you and
Michael Phelps both I'm just saying
2,000 years ago some some random dude
decided to start putting needles in
people and you think that the science
backs that up there's no shot they know
back then and they never changed it
they didn't update it they're like no
the needles still go in the skin okay
dude I didn't have an opportunity to
read it to you but I did find some uh
NIH acupuncture stuff and they they
weren't like you know maybe they're
being diplomatic but they weren't
actually totally dismissive of it I
think like Chiro
racy and I do know that um doctors refer
out it's even covered by a lot of
insurances for like chiropracty and
acupuncture because I do think that with
there's people that have symptoms that
you
know are
not they're either not responding to
other treatments or and sometimes maybe
it's not severe enough to Warrant like
going on you know some medication yeah
you don't want to give people p
opiate that's the last thing you want to
do I suppose it is that's a good point
sending somebody to acupuncturist is
less harmful than prescribing them some
Valium or whatever the oh yeah
definitely and so um I think there's
probably a fair bit of
um what's it called when you think
something works even though Placebo yeah
thank well they even call that out here
I'll read you the sentence this is on
the NIH uh that's called identity do
website uh how acupuncture works is not
fully understood however there is
evidence that acupuncture may have
effects on the nervous system effects on
other body tissue and non-specific and
then in parenthesis it says Placebo
effects the thing is the body is pretty
incredible like when you're Placebo is a
real phenomenon like if you take some
medicine that you're convince works it
it it can really do something your body
so so the placebo thing is
it is real but
like that the way that it's administered
you know whatever so I mean I'm not like
don't do this you know some people it's
good for them and they believe it and
that's what's that's what works you know
what I mean
sure but if you're not in like chronic
extreme pain where you like literally
need opiates to
survive then you know it's better to try
other things yeah if it gives you any
relief at all the cupping stuff though I
don't know about that one that shit's
crazy I just really don't know what's
being accomplish don't you agree the
fact that that was invented like uh 100
years ago makes it even shadier than
acupuncture cuz at least there's like wa
cupping is recent she said it was a 100
years ago cuz I thought that it was
another Chinese thing oh yeah I don't I
don't trust any medicine made in the
like 19th century that's where the
chiropracty stuff came from too that's
what I was saying dude I don't trust
those idiots
Century of B like at least there's
like voodoo magic and like mystical uh
uh you know ancestory stuff about
chiropracty cupping is just some
weirdo
putting burning cotton balls bruising
the out of your back I'm seeing
that Roman surgeons may have been using
it uh back 400 uh 460 BC the cupping
thing I mean maybe for different
practices but I'm seeing conflicting
things I'm seeing that 14th and 17th
centuries between then is when it got
popular but I'm seeing it may have been
used okay so maybe it's been around for
a while I don't know the weird thing
with cupping is that I see so many
athletes doing it oh yeah I don't know
what that
means yeah it's just so bizarre they do
they're Well yeah if it does if it does
increase blood circulation I guess
theoretically it could do something and
these Elite athletes are their bodies
are so up and worn out that like
yeah I'm pretty sure they're desperate
for any really keep them going those
guys do so much on their body maybe if
you do it enough it just feels good and
which case fine like the way a massage
feels good like I don't think a massage
is generally uh improving your health
but that doesn't mean it's not relaxing
I think Mass I think massages are
there's probably way
better um evidence behind massages than
the cupping stuff yeah the cupping and
the acup
that feels right to
me yeah I mean you're massaging the
muscles you're loosening the muscles
thing is that cupping it just sucks your
skin up it doesn't suck your muscle up
how could it I think if you do it
intense enough it grabs a decent amount
of muscle tissue under there like I
don't no it's not that she it's funny
your your back looks really bruised but
the I've seen people do it and there's
like way more yeah for sure stuff that
comes up into the cup dude I can't is
that I mean it was like painful not
horrible but yeah doing it way more than
that would be it's crazy here I look
like a Pizza
Pie
nice W that one's crazy yeah it's like
solid Golly Golly she is and I mean I
guess the blood does stay there for a
while or is that that's probably just
your skin I think it's just literally
bruising yeah it's just skin well
bruising is blood small blood vessels
yeah it's like exactly right just like
blood in your skin I think technically
Cy may cause breaks in capillaries in
the papillary dermis layer of the skin
resulting in the appearance of
perur uh perur okay all right let's
watch our boy all right let's thank our
supporters and then let's go okay so
here he is M do M.T or whatever is that
his name m r r r
sexm gu slay this guy Slayer
420 we finally found
him H here I
love
[Music]
p
does he have other songs he does but
this he's he's this is his moment okay
got it he might be my new favorite
person I love him hands down he's got he
seems like a good energy too good VI I
mean if if people are not having a
problem with the jamaan thing then then
I'm cool it's not my place to say but
people don't seem offended by it I've
seen him work with yeah I see people
like Jamaican people so yeah they see I
think the Jamaican people like him okay
yeah I mean in many well I'm not
speaking for everyone but I've seen him
collaborating with Jamaican people and
they all seem like pretty dope all right
yeah Slayer 420
Blaze we found him yeah boy see I don't
like this comment the 14th minute of his
15 minutes of fame is here shut up dude
it's install M.T forever are
our haters this is minute one
haters I get so annoyed at people saying
15 minutes of F and like that even
if that would be true wouldn't wouldn't
you be dumb not to ride your 15 minutes
yeah sense hey that's absolutely true
man you got to ride it for what it
is and he's loving it this guy's been
doing music for a long ass
time look at that
crowd
[Applause]
yo That's My Boy Tough of
[Music]
hair dude we got Jamaican Flags in the
audience and
yeah hold on go ahead I'm just
curious do we know his uh background
yeah he's British he's just a British he
is British he had a family because I was
there there are white Jamaicans oh you
know what he does have an interesting
story Wonder maybe he just was Jamaican
his stepdad is Jamaican God it okay
there so actually there is some there's
a connection yeah there is a connection
got it okay well fair enough did I Jo my
that right something like that maybe
even sister step sister possi his
brother-in-law is Jamaican something
like that okay that's starting to
and he grew up with someone
Jamaican I think we talked about it on a
scent we we yeah yeah look at this he's
he's throwing a party called turn red
how the is
red uh there's this one of him doing a
freestyle it's so good oh here it is and
they stop OG right yeah dude I love this
one they stop him right when he starts
cooking
dude Mone F
when there everybody G look lion
sound
[Music]
acting that's not the one I was thinking
of oh
this everything
play
deerland West wake up in the morning got
good attack bro he's got good energy man
mhm he's out there
got the was white look at
this dude this guy's living his best
life right now look at this
turn all around the world baby all
around the world that's right all around
the world turn
red big bumba clad I love him
dude The Vibes are good he seems like a
nice guy oh here he's getting tatted up
I just want
to I'm putting all my horses in this
guy's reputation I love thisy he seems
like a really good he never done
anything wrong I'm I'm with you love
hell yeah I'm with you I'm not going to
go that
far not that I think he is a bad person
Dan you don't know him like like we do
I've seen three three videos
so yeah yo I'm telling you the artwork
that he's gave me on the arm is crazy
people we got the life for the greatest
cuz life is just great right now also we
got soul plus we got Gio is gifted me
the M thing man look on the col donkeys
crazy gifted me these I I'm so not a
sneakerhead I feel like all the shoes
look the same are they all the same just
like it's just different color on like
this the little side panel yeah but
those colors make the shoe depending on
the color and the color way it makes the
shoe go up or down I know but it's like
yo they made want a beige it's like okay
yo dude there's one with black on it
I need that hash no pandas I
probably pissing off the sneaker head
yeah you
are yo did you see that one it has red
panels um I I dropped a time stamp that
we watched before of him explaining his
sister when he was a kid dated a man
from Jamaica oh good okay here not
brother-in pretty loose his older sister
did when I was very very young pretty
pretty loose um my El elder sister who
is quite a bit older than me she was uh
in a relationship with somebody from
Jamaica in England yeah so our family
was always around um you know when I was
young when I was like I mean like 9 10
we' we'd have Christmas at our house and
then we'd go to like my sister's
Partners family yes and uh everyone was
Jamaican so I used to like steal their
lyrics and just take them back and just
kind like like use part of it and then
change a little part of it and add my
little part to it so even when I really
really started started you know DJing it
was it was my brother-in-laws I was kind
of stealing the lyrics from so that's
where where the influence was straight
away right from when I was like 9 10 so
when you met them seems to be a com in
the music industry what what seems to be
a common Trope in the music industry
just stealing white artist stealing
from black artist black artist he's the
El of it's a time it is a Timeless uh
story and he's like why he's like
throwing in Jamaican accent in just his
normal speech too it's like he's really
good at it though you're not from
Jamaica his is better than Chad's I I
made the joke the last time he's
Kingston right
Kingston I'm looking at an interview he
did and in it it says that um for lunch
he had a hot chocolate with cream and a
bacon
sandwich that's crazy that is a crazy
meal what a meal it's my boy right there
UPS to the island of
[Music]
Britain is this not track I didn't know
what the that was
okay here what's this go
ahead fans in the airport we got I found
him ping we always hide that is it
people got oh come on Dan this guy sucks
what how are you going to say that cuz
he has one song and he does a fake
Jamaican accent because his sister dated
a Jamaican guy for like a month when he
was a kid it's weird he went to Jamaican
Christmas it's weird and then
he's bragging about stealing his music
from he was nine he was telling us I
know I know but it's just the vi the
vibe is not good I don't like the vibe
I'm out this is what happens to haters
I'm out you see this yeah it's for you
Dan we're watching we're
watching I'll you big bmba clot
uhhuh we clut over here clot
Fu when I was very very young uh so
that's my boy um Dan Dan is not a fan
but he's my boy M.R shut up you tried to
sell me on him and it had the opposite
effect you know what can you do okay
well it's it's nice to have different
perspectives perspectives Gary ve said
can you believe steo was like I had Gary
ve he was telling me the the way to fix
deep fix is
crypto I was like what the hell that
loser or not crypto he said uh
blockchain blockchain yeah
yeah all right let's thank our our
lovely
supporters uh you talking about the
super chats IE it okay yeah thank you
thank you everyone for supporting us
thank you to all of our members you know
yall make a big diff out here Jay fell
says don't forget me please oh right we
said we would watch his uh music video
today um he was the guy who did the
cowat Kev Dis Track he was a finalist in
that competition okay so
Wednesday well I mean we have guest on
Wednesday I mean you want to send it
I'll watch it now yeah yeah if you if
you like he's Don it maybe 10 times
today okay I'll watch it I'll watch it
there's a little bit of a there's a
desperation going on here so let's let's
take care of our boy um two speed if we
don't get bites can we at least get a
few nibbles what does that
mean if we don't get bites can we at
least get a few
I don't know what that means that was
very early in the show sexual fantasy
first donation is about the time stamp I
mean the sound bites if we don't get
bites can we get nibbles maybe okay okay
okay um Elena thank you Alejandro thank
you so much appreciate you shout out to
the gorgeous women from Blaze Pizza who
recognized I was wearing Teddy fresh you
made my year want to be friends I got
shy and did not ask for your number in
front of 20 coworkers bro
you doing a misconnections right now in
the super chats of the a podcast
Alejandro just go back dude back back
yeah go back you know where she's works
yeah go get yourself a pizza and be like
I be slick be like this yeah I'll take a
large pepperoni pizza and uh you'll be
joining me over here for lunch oh got
itler alert he has no pizza experience L
Ollie bad boy thank you for the Don I
just went a week without alcohol for the
first time in 12 years steo helped me to
know I'll be okay without it awesome
congratulations that's great and Novak
they actually showed me videos of them
when I was in
rehab
Novak they showed me videos of Novak
when I was in rehab might be referring
to Brandon Novak he's a friend of steo
oh okay oh okay oh okay okay well anyway
congratulations keep it up olly yeah
it's worth it it's worth it you don't
need it you don't need it Cass thank you
so much I'm 2.5 months sober off of hard
drugs thank you sto for being a positive
life for people in recovery and thank
you H3 for helping me laugh through hard
times been watching since ABCD EFG wow
damn that's a goodie that's an oldi and
goodie thank you Cass thank you so much
and good luck man you it's worth it stay
sober folks coming up on seven years off
the sauce okay wow so lots of people uh
moved this is actually Jay fella 7 years
off the sauce my wife is four years
sober from opas we have two kids and
we're close to losing everything we
overcame it but it never but it's never
over I keep my bottom in my back pocket
as a reminder keep my
bottom like Rock Bottom oh I keep
metaphorically I keep my bottom in my
back pocket as a reminder he thinks
about it so that he never relapses I
think that's nice blessed anyway that's
that's a that's a crazy story I mean wow
if you guys were both having drug
problems with kids that that's that's
intense but I'm happy for you guys keep
it up
man I mean it sounds like you all are
good for you I've got Alexa K thank you
I've gone through the process of
exorcism it sucks and it's really
consuming cath Catholic exorcism is real
but some of this this video
is
somatic why am I conf every one of these
has something I don't understanding it
what is somatic relating to the body as
distinct from the mind oh
okay thank you Jay fella again in Jesus
name do not forget my video Jay fella
again should I stop wasting my kids
college tuition bro so I mean yeah a
Super Chat St desperate to be heard yes
dude don't do that go charge back
YouTube pleas I don't you know what I
mean
h all right let me watch your video bro
and then you can charge back
youTube all right this guy's giving shoe
nice but not an
addict all
right here we go this is it this is the
uh this is the story of how the H3
podcast um basically ruined my life I
mean shatter my dreams every single hope
and dream I ever had to
shatter in my life not only did we win
H3 ruined my life just like that ruined
my life I also fell with the 5% 5% do
you realize how much 5% was of our last
one that should be enough but also like
highlights
and single hope and dream that I ever
had his 5% to send Jeff basos to the
moon for J F I know he was uh I was sad
when he didn't make it I was like oh
that was I thought he might win but it
was close man it was Jay fella and who
the guy everyone was riding
for kiss
you my wife wants it every night morning
and afternoon I know she's my wife but
rather you can have a too cuz there's a
few things I treasure in life Pon scheme
suing Ethan and Brad my wife
companies and paying for lights and the
on ain't nothing it man I'm suing
them twice hey Ryan what's for breakfast
a we and Reckless this so my third time
I hav't learned my lesson is making up
of a first impression they call him cut
cuz up in his first Direction geted in
media at home in bed like Wikipedia they
writing mean things that are guy name
but don't be
alarmed
abouty and wav the balance and by way
man shame St that shit's foul some say
the7 why you dress so childish trailer
the things flip feed of the lent and
don't get me started and why you got
sequence you're a millionaire
get your can't even pay an any man that
Cav's a cheap
[Applause]
[Music]
so
good his lyrics
were know
we man we call that fraud
man yeah wow
how
iuin I think we're about to find out
just roll on y that it's like the H3
family um brought me back to a whole
another state of mind like I I
didn't I was so I was just done with
music basically it was crazy I was just
like you know what I'm too old there's
no there's no point of it there's a lot
that came about my mom passed in in
22 um and that hit me I mean
that hit me so
hard the 20 plus years I've been making
music I never received that type of love
and it was on some freaking Ryan
Cavanaugh dist was fire
bro like the you know people from the
fan were still reaching out and they're
like we want more you know we want
more and so I started posting some of my
old
stuff hey J fella it's
hold on this is not a cameo then what is
it where did you get this did you get
this from my mom other okay all right
your message and first of all I want to
thank you for participating in the
contest and losing by 5% really sucks
it's so close it's such a small amount
you know but obviously you were
certainly one of the crowd favorites my
God losing by only 5% said but you know
don't take it to heart you're good at
what you do you're talented keep doing
it you know it's a lot of fun and you're
good at it and as far as putting you on
Ethan's live show you know Ethan's his
own man I'm just his mom I don't have
any saying anything although I'm going
to see him tomorrow for Thanksgiving so
you know what I'll tell him that I got
this video from you and we'll Le we'll
see where that leads did she tell you
anyways I don't remember okay I guess
probably I don't know thank you for
being such a wonderful fan and keep up
the good work we love you have a great
Thanksgiving ciao ciao how did I ruin
his life uh being silly I think he's
he's being listen Jay fella if you want
to keep making diss tracks I'll I'll
keep playing them bro you know what I
mean you got a you got a pension for it
my guy who who should we put put Jay
fella on next I mean we don't have
another oh oh a Shetty diss track would
be awesome J shett J fella on J
shett Jay squared bro J Jay squared okay
Jay uh you you reading this you copy
this
yeah Jay said he's goingon to regret the
day he left me on
red um that'd be epic yeah yeah knock
one out we'll we'll happily play that
yeah we'll we'll bump it and then
finally there was one more James uh
shames shames Jr Dan is telling the
truth here I wish so it's just I don't
know where where it is shame Dan is
telling the truth here that's what they
said oh okay I think that was in
reference to uh
M.C whatever his name is m you found
your your hater
friends Shetty dude shett I wonder
[Music]
if okay we'll talk I got some ideas
we'll talk after the show thank you guys
love y'all thanks for being here had a
fun show good show exciting show thank
you to our members thank you to all of
our supporters you guys are
uh make it all possible here so thank
you thank you thank
you we let the rler
talk done was getting
by
[Music]
baby
even in
the forn oh we have stabos on
Wednesday so look forward to that
fortnite and
was fornite M see you tomorrow I don't
know what we're doing though a baby GR
in fortnite
fornite looks like a how Mandel
prol